ready thank you okay
okay
for the members here uh when you speak
uh ask a question uh to my members uh
you have there's a button you hit and
you'll see the red light will come on
when you get done shut it off so we
don't get any you know um stuff to the
the speaker system there okay and the
same thing we I'm sure you know
welcome uh representative Charlotte
thank you Mr chairman I'll take my mask
off although I'm told I looked better
with the mask on but I like the beard by
the way well thank you yeah
yeah surprised it came in Gray
Mr chairman for the record my name is
Steve shortliff and I represent
Merrimack District 11 which is wad one
of conquered the village of Penacook and
I'm here this morning to introduce the
committee uh house bill 1050.
let me just die Mr chairman by telling
the committee what this bill isn't this
bill is not intended in any way to
diminish Veterans Day that takes place
on November 11th as a veteran
especially as the Via War veteran uh I
have tremendous respect and admiration
for anybody who served in our Armed
Forces whether in time of War what this
bill simply does is
asked the governor to issue a
proclamation that
that declares that November 11th in New
Hampshire will also be known as
Remembrance Day
all right
that is not a state holiday
the governor issues several
proclamations throughout the year
honoring different days for example in
June he issues a proclamation honoring
the Marquis De lafayette's a visit to
New Hampshire in June of 1825 so it's
simply a remembrance by the state or
acknowledgment by the state
then enough status is also known as
Remembrance Day
um as I'm sure you know Mr chairman
November 11th Max the end of World War
One when that war ended on the 11th day
of the 11th month at the 11th Hour
and then that war over 400 000 Americans
died uh I think it was 670 000 were
casualties
twenty four thousand five hundred were
Marines Mr chairman and it was really it
was said to be the war to end all wars
but it wasn't
um and I just hope
that on that date that we remember those
of world war one that died and uh and
those that didn't come home
I will add that I'm as a veteran
I'm somewhat disappointed in our own
Memorial Day and what's happened uh in
the lack of true recognition of that day
in May
um
that date started May 30th in 1868 when
the Grand Army of the Republic the four
would decorate Graves of Fallen Union
Souls
churches and um
and they picked that date because no
major battle took place they wanted
people to Simply focus on those that
died and not on any battle
and then in 1968 Congress passed and the
president signed a bill making Memorial
Day a Monday holiday
um
it was said it was done because of the
fuel crisis others that it was done
because to make to help the tourist
industry whatever the reason
um
if you ask most New Hampshire citizens
what Memorial Day means they'll tell you
that it it's the first day of summer or
a time to buy a new vehicle or an
appliance it's they've lost the meaning
this bill
acknowledging Remembrance Day and the
end of World War One
uh is simply
to do simply that remember the war dead
of the first World War
and I'll close by saying my mom was born
in Ireland and she used to tell me that
there's an old Irish saying
that it's better to give one rose to the
living than a dozen for the Dead
in what I see this bill doing
on Veterans Day
is always giving a dozen roses to our
living veterans and thanking them for
this service but maybe just setting
aside one rose for the dead on that date
and just remembering those that did give
their life for our country
you know someone who has seen Americans
shed their blood in Florence oil I think
anytime we can remember our war dead
it's always good but of course it's
always Veterans Day in honoring the
living but not forgetting our debt do we
have any questions for
um representative
Mr chair and thank you representative
for taking my question
will the day be known as veterans and
Remembrance Day or veterans Remembrance
Day it'll always be Veterans Day period
the only time remembrance would be used
would be that the governor signs the
proclamation saying that in New
Hampshire it's also a day of remembrance
for the end of world war one but it's
always it always will be in New
Hampshire Veterans Day there are many
days that take place throughout the year
that the governor recognizes a lot of
times we don't even hear about them such
as Lafayette day and other dates it's
just something
it's something I know and we know that
it is also Remembrance Day and not to
make a big celebration out or ought to
try to deflect from uh Veterans Day
is there any other questions
I get a couple of questions again for
you to representative how many states uh
call A Remembrance Day I don't believe
any state does to my knowledge
you know what Mr chairman to add on to
your question if you go to Canada on the
11th whether you watch the news and you
see the newscasters wearing poppies or
if you're going to a Tim Hortons for
coffee the staff is wearing white
poppies and as I said Veterans Day is a
day that everyone should be honoring our
living Veterans for this service but if
somebody wanted to wear a poppy on that
day just in their own hat to remember
those that passed that would be fine
especially in the first world war no I
agree I've been wearing the poppy here
for about 15 years that we're on my I
might wear my VV not Veterans of America
or pen every day and when I say the
pledge my index finger goes on that to
remind me of those that didn't come home
now for some reason it popping in my
head Armistice Day and I'm not an old
history buff the air of course in the
Marine Corps we're required to do a lot
of reading on strategic you know
moves and how people other countries uh
train
um homage Daves for some reason was
initiated in I think Europe or something
well Amazon
official in I'm sorry I didn't mean to
Interruption my question is why not
honesty
um I like the idea that most of the
commonwealth countries call it
Remembrance Day and not Armistice Day
and that's what I would like to see us
today Armistice Day means that's the day
when the Axis powers and the Allies
signed the peace treaty in the war ended
I want us to remember instead those that
didn't come home those that gave the
last full measure on the battlefield I'd
rather have him remember
thank you representative thank you for
your service thank you do you have
written testimony at all no sir okay I
think I do have um I don't have a
question but I just want to take a
moment and say thank you for your
service and then this is an amazing idea
this is an amazing build for me for
someone who has uh relatives they've
been in a service it's it's good to know
that someone is thinking about
having this day representing you know
for those those that lost their life and
those the one that sacrifices a lot just
to serve our country thank you so much
questions
thank you thank you Mr chairman thank
you
Joe I recognize uh representative
renzullo
I can breathe again
thank you very thank you very much Mr
chairman members of the committee
is this better love it uh
I'm uh Andy renzullo I represent the
Hudson and Pelham Hillsborough 37.
those who do not learn from history are
doomed to repeat it
actually those are the original the
original form of the George Santana
quote
is that those who cannot remember the
past are condemned to repeat it
that's who that's
why we need to observe
Remembrance Day
World War One Is The Forgotten War
the last American World War One veteran
died in 2010.
what happened from 1914 to 1918 shocked
the world and changed the world forever
it was a war like no one had ever
imagined at that time people called it
the Great War and the war to end all
wars
30 Nations fought military tactics of
the 19th century
met the military met the
met the military technology of the 20th
century
Millions literally millions died
two million German soldiers 1.1 million
British soldiers 1.4 million French
soldiers
1.8 million Russians
these these countries lost whole Genera
a whole generation
of young men
the U.S lost 117 000 killed in action
great Empires fell the Russian Empire
the austro-hungarian Empire the Ottoman
Empire were shattered
a slew of new nations emerged and
re-emerged Poland Czechoslovakia
Yugoslavia Finland to name just some
in the peoples of the Middle East were
no longer under the ottoman rule
there's so much more to tell communism
nationalism fascism
suffice it to say that many of the
world's problems even today have their
roots in World War one and its aftermath
I can talk about that for the rest of
the day
but I won't
uh November 11th used to be called
Armistice Day in the United States
that was picked up after the uh after
the end of the war because on the 11th
hour or the 11th day or the 11th month
of my 1918 the guns went silent
in 1954 the holiday was changed to
Veterans Day to honor all veterans and
that is as it should be
but we should also remember Remembrance
Day
to denote a time when the world changed
cataclysmically
and we and we do not
become quote those who do not learn from
history and are doomed to repeat it
but as Americans just we just as we
celebrate July 4th as an as our nation's
birthday
let us at least Remember the Time
the American United States of America
became an adult
among the Nations and ceased to be a
regional power and became a world power
as you have as that that's my prepared
amount by prepared tax as far as
remem Remembrance Day much of the
British Commonwealth
uh celebrates remembrance the
Remembrance Day uh
the Australians and new zealanders it's
Anzac Day
uh
and I remember as a youngster when
uh in the in the 50s
uh
we it was it was poppy we we wore the
poppy
it was it was more important than
Lisa as a kid as than Memorial Day
because you had the World War One vets
were still alive
and
and the World War II vets had come back
it was a far more powerful holiday then
than it is than than it is but that is
that is that's been replaced by Veterans
Day as I say and that's that is a good
thing
but we also should need to remember
that's why I remembered today
any questions thank you representative
Dom you take questions I take sure
absolutely any questions for
Representatives
well come on I could spend the rest of
the day talking about World War One if
you'd like well I want to thank you
hello love that stuff a lot of a lot of
my fellow Marines from the past have was
there and as representative Shirley said
helping out the Army you know
thank you
they do
you want the answer
okay the chair recognized Uh Kevin Grady
from the state veterans advisory
committee
what would you do here okay good morning
Mr chairman ladies and gentlemen of the
committee I really have a couple things
I want to take care of this morning the
first is for those of you that don't
know what we do I'm here today well
first of all I'm my name is Kevin Grady
I have uh after a 25-year career in our
Air Force I've lived in Hooksett for the
last 23 years uh Mr Grady can I stop you
for a minute I have absolutely two cards
here I got me
okay I'm sorry there was a confusion got
put in my same pile I'm sorry different
builds I'm here a lot this morning so I
figured I'd fill out the cards in
advance and give them to uh to the
chairman
um as I said I'm a 25-year uh military
veteran from the Air Force I'm also a
um a 23-year resident of Hooksett
um the state veterans advisory committee
is why I'm here today I represent the
state veterans advisory committee and
the opinions that I'm going to tell you
this morning are theirs not mine it's
the the consensus of of the group number
one there's 20 members for those of you
unfamiliar with what we do there's 20
member organizations of our committee
and we're chartered by state RSA to
actually speak for the veteran community
and so one of the things we do is we
look at all of the bills out there that
we think have better an impact and then
we discuss them and take a position on
them and then I come and tell you what
they thought
um they they were not high they were not
very fired up about this bill
um we think the idea of Veterans Day
is it kind of speaks for itself you
start calling it something else it it it
tends to muddy the waters a little bit
and if you read what the bill actually
asked the governor to do which is to
just send out a proclamation and suggest
that cities and towns do activities and
parades and things like that but we're
already doing those kind of things
um when I I taught Air Force Junior ROTC
down at Auburn High School in Hudson for
11 years and we always used to teach our
students that we really have two days a
year that are set aside for these kinds
of celebrations we have Memorial Day
which is set aside for those veterans
that have passed either in battle or or
served in a wartime and have since
passed and then we have Veterans Day
that honors all veterans but the idea of
a Remembrance Day is now we're we're now
kind of tying that a little bit towards
that the World War One veterans which
we're accounting for on on Memorial Day
the last thing that I want to do is you
may have heard from your constituents
about this because I know I heard from
mine but about two years ago the
adjutant general came to us and said
what do you want to do about Veterans
Day
so those of you who've been around for a
while used to know we had a a ceremony
up at the state that the state Cemetery
every year at about 11 o'clock in the
morning and we had the governor there we
had all our political our Congressional
Delegation was always there and and a
lot of the leaders of all of these
veterans groups had to be there and in
order to do that they had to skip what
was going on in their hometowns
and so they the we we talked about it
and we said we would rather be
in our home towns doing the celebrations
there with our our local people than we
would be doing a Statewide thing in in
boscoin well you probably heard about
that from your constituents and we heard
about it from our constituents too
um the only thing I could tell you is
that probably later on this fall when we
get we get cranked back up in September
or October we're going to discuss this
again and and we may make a different
decision for 2022 and going forward but
that's really all I wanted to tell you
this morning unless you have any
questions you'll see me again though
thank you a lot today well I made it
easy so I could get you all here in one
day I appreciate that Mr chairman maybe
we can get the uh Soldier behind you to
hang out and listen to some of the
veterans stuff there perhaps shortly but
anyways are there any uh questions uh
for Kevin Grady
thank you do you have any written
testimony at all you always speak from
the heart anyways all right thanks thank
you representative razulo do you have
written testimony with that you had
given
that would be nice
okay
um seeing that there is no more
um cards does anyone else want to speak
that has not uh filled out a card
all right thank you I'm going to close
the hearing on HB 1050 and in about 10
minutes we'll go into 1092.
for the representatives that came in
late uh there's packages up you have all
the bills in that box so help okay thank
you that's very good
yeah for uh for state and federal
relation for the
um I
we're going to be doing nine bills a day
today nine bills nine bills next
Thursday and then one bill on uh that
Friday morning so that way they just go
back to work and do whatever you've got
to do that's why I put all this here to
make it easier for you is that I have a
lot of young Representatives on this yet
I think it all worked so get it done
ready for um
you just want to get him get those two
on board
I agree with with the job
now during the testimony if you have a
computer on your desk you want to make
sure that you're paying attention to uh
people speaking and not typing and doing
stuff on your computer because
I just want to make sure that we give
the respect to who's speaking
I don't know
and I know you're a job yeah I know that
but you know
did you see his card oh here it is
it another pile
and then
foreign
if you take a look on your desk too I
had our researcher which did a great job
to research what bills that have been in
this committee before so give you an
idea
on where we're at on on any other bills
that come forward that have been here
it looks like there's more of them
sounds like a joke
the official declaration of war thing
there was a bill like that oh yeah
oh
yeah
oh no because it was on the consent
calendar
definitely Authority
yeah I wrote I wrote that up yeah
um
can we get uh ready we're gonna get
ready to start the committee can we
please representative
12 minutes
okay
I'm going to open up the hearing on
House Bill 1092 requiring official
declaration of war for the activation of
the New Hampshire National Guard and I'm
going to recognize the prime sponsor
representative Bellinger
welcome to the committee rep Bellinger
thank you Mr chairman for the record
it's representative Belanger and I
represent the beautiful center of the
universe Epping
um
before you get started is Jim your dad
no no okay Jim Ellen Belanger yeah no I
get that a lot okay he's a veteran I was
wondering okay
um that leads me to my next Point um for
the record I myself am not a veteran but
uh
I represent a community of blue-collar
workers many who are veterans and I was
asked to submit this piece of
legislation on behalf of a few of them
in town
first I'd like to thank you for
listening to my testimony today and on
this bill and I want to thank those
behind me for being here today
HP 1092fn
um
I got myself out of whack here sorry
I apologize uh
So I myself am not a veteran however I
represent a community of blue collar
workers many who are veterans
um I had a constituent reach out and
point me in the direction of this piece
of legislation and so I put it together
for him
it's an issue that I do agree with
otherwise I wouldn't have submitted this
legislation in the first place I have a
lot of respect for the individual and
that's why it's been drafted
you've heard something similar to this
in the past and it always tends to come
up that we're going to lose millions of
dollars so on
other states have proposed the same
legislation and yet they do not see a
reduction in their spending
the intent of the National Guard is to
insist the state when necessary for
example military nurses and doctors
being deployed to Community Hospitals
during the covid-19 pandemic
we've seen Wars wage on for generations
and we've seen presidents remove
military personnel from countries
recklessly
this bill would require an official
declaration of war by Congress which for
the record is required by the
Constitution to declare war in the first
place
we've
[Music]
um
we've seen presidents prolonged War
this needs to stop and hopefully it
starts today
please join me in passing this important
piece of legislation for our National
Guard soldiers in New Hampshire
OTP
uh thank you representative will you
take questions of course and I tell you
don't have written uh testimony no but I
can send it send it to representative of
course thank you any questions for uh
representative moffatt
thank you Mr thank you representative
Belanger for for being here and uh very
interesting and important issue my
question has to do with the New
Hampshire International Guard and I
believe there's a refueling unit or
refueling Squadron out of peas and I
know that during some of our recent uh
Undeclared conflicts so to speak the
Middle East that that we feel that New
Hampshire refueling of it there may be
some folks here who could later speak to
that uh was activated now the reserve
component in the National Guard
components sometimes are activated or
federalized so the the mission of this
refueling outfit was crucial to getting
you know some of the airplanes some of
the air power across the ocean so
my question is if this were to move
forward and become law would this
preclude uh the the utilization of this
particular refueling outfit that
apparently in the past has been needed
by the by the Air Force
no because it does thank you
representative moffatt for your question
and thank you for pronouncing my name
correctly
um
in in the way that I view this piece of
legislation it does not because it allow
you know you still putting the power in
the state
so it gives the ability of the governor
to be able to do that
so it should be necessary Governor still
has the power of the National Guard to
give them orders as they see fit because
that's just what the National Guard was
meant to do in the first place
follow-up follow-up okay thank you so
from what I understand from your
response then is that
If This Were to pass then this refueling
unit or some like reserve or guy or I
should say National Guard unit if the uh
if the president or or the Pentagon
needed that support they would have to
just go through our governor and then he
would sign on to support it if he wanted
to that would be the intent yes sir okay
thank you
thank you for taking my question uh
representative Belanger
um I was just wondering what other
states have passed this legislation
I'm not familiar with that unfortunately
I'm not
I didn't bring my iPad
thank you for letting me have a
follow-up Mr chairman thank you for
taking another question representative
um so National Guardsmen serve under the
Dual enlistment uh since 1916 so they're
both part of the state militia and uh
Federal forces so I was wondering is a
declaration of war needed to mobilize
federal troops at any time
yeah
are you familiar with the Constitution
representative Brody
um representative deshays and yes
certainly can you answer don't ask my
committee members any question can you
answer the question he asked please
thank you
Congress is required to uh
declare a declaration of war
and it is required every 30 days to do
so
technically that's not being done
follow-up good my question wasn't in
regard to mobilizing troops for a war it
was in regards to mobilizing troops for
any kind of action respectfully I think
I answered the question the best way
that I can okay thank you
one else I have a couple here um are you
aware that this bill has been here in
2008 2012 and 2021 yes that's why I said
that okay are you aware that
um there was a case a few years ago and
I left my um stuff on my desk at my
house and I don't know if it was
Minnesota versus the us or
one of the states uh on this same issue
where they said that the president
didn't have the authority to activate
the national God and that they could
stop it and the court said no you're
wrong uh the president does have the
authority are you aware of that
so I am aware that there is
there may be case law but I am not
familiar with that specific case law no
okay my next question to you would be
that
um under this here bill
um are you well first of all are you
familiar with title 10
okay I'm not going to educate John right
now but
um I I would think that in the future
that you would take a look at title 10
versus title 32 and that you'll look at
the U.S Constitution under the
president's duties uh to activate
the uh the militia
for the you know safety of the U.S or
however it's worded without pulling out
the Constitution then if you look at the
New Hampshire Constitution it gives the
guidance to the governor on you know as
the commander-in-chief but throughout
the years the president once he
activates Governors have no choice are
you aware of that
yes I'm aware of that I was not aware of
that that title 10 is what you were
referring to okay thank you are there
any other questions you have
okay uh thank you for your testimony and
um if you have written if you can send
it to uh we'll do that right now thank
you thank you Mr chair the chair will
recognize
um Mr Kevin Grady
from the state veterans advisory
committee
welcome once again
thank you Mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen again for the record my name
is Kevin Grady 25-year Air Force veteran
uh 23-year veteran of Hooksett today
representing the state veterans advisory
committee
um we unanimously oppose this
legislation
um and since this morning has been a
little bit about history uh let's let's
talk just a little bit about about
history because it really Bears on this
particular legislation
most people think that we we last had
Congress declare war right after the
Japanese attacked Pearl Harbor but the
truth of the matter is if you look it up
it was actually on the 5th of June of
1942 where we sort of declared war
against uh Bulgaria and Hungary and
Romania it's a sort of clean up who we
were fighting against already over there
in 1942 and that is the last time that
Congress actually declared uh War but
that doesn't mean that Congress hasn't
been involved okay in 1964 to North
Korea and uh I'm sorry in North
Vietnamese Patrol Boats were stupid
enough to fire on the USS Navy and were
sunk and people went to to the Congress
and they said they're shooting at our
boys over there in Vietnam and the
Congress passed the Tonkin Gulf
resolution which basically said Mr
President here's a blank check go spend
whatever you want to spend out there
well after the Vietnam years and some of
you are in here are veterans of that
time
um the Congress said boy that was a
terrible idea and they passed What's
called the War Powers Resolution of
1973. and what that basically says is Mr
President you can go anyplace in the
world that you want to go to to defend
American interests but after 30 days and
this is where the 30 Days part comes in
after 30 days if you don't get an
authorization from us in the Congress in
order to use Force then we can do what
we do Congress controls the military
because they control the money the cash
okay that's how that that whole process
works and
so if you look at history since then why
did President George H.W bush go ask the
Congress for a resolution for the use of
force when he went to Desert Storm
because he's required to by the War
Powers Resolution of 73. same thing for
President George W Bush when he decided
to go to Iraq in 2003 why did he get
Congress to authorize that because he's
required to so the Congress is already
involved in a lot of these things even
though they haven't actually declared
war and if you look at things since then
you will see instances Like Us in Syria
during the Obama Administration where we
didn't go in there for too long because
they knew they weren't going to be able
to get an authorization for the use of
force from the Congress so the Congress
is still involved in all this
keeping with my history theme
after Desert Storm the military across
the board downsized to a pretty small
version and I got to tell you from when
that happened especially in the air
force that I represent all right which
right now the Air Force has less
airplanes than at any time since we
became a separate service in 1947 okay
so the guard in the reserve forces that
we have around our country are not a
nice to have anymore they're a must-have
and as the representative said
um the tanker unit at peas is there for
a reason they're they're there to drag
airplanes across the pond in both
directions and the active duty military
needs that support every single day in
order to do their mission they
absolutely need it every single day and
the guard and the reserve forces that
you would find if you went out and
talked to somebody at peas that flies
tankers he would tell you you know
sometimes I fly one of ours sometimes I
fly an active duty tanker sometimes I
fly somebody else's tanker okay the
crews are interchangeable the airplanes
are interchangeable the whole operation
is kind of interchangeable there really
is no such thing as our National Guard
forces deploying on mass without the
governor and the the adjutant general
knowing about this well in advance okay
most of the time it's going to require
some training that they're going to have
to go to before they go down range it's
all coordinated I'm not talking get
about a couple months in advance I'm
talking years in advance and this is all
coordinated the governor knows it
representative albusero talked about
title 10 at any time the president can
say I'm putting our people under title
10 orders and because we're paying the
bill we the federal government are
paying the bill we the taxpayers are
paying the bill the governor really
doesn't have the ability to say nah I
don't think so I think I'm going to keep
my my taker guys home this weekend I'm
not I'm not sending them when you when
you put them on on federal orders
a lot of people don't realize this you
know you know about the guard will they
work one weekend a month they work
um one uh one or two weeks a year during
the summer or some other time when they
can tell you who pays for that federal
government it gets routed through the
state but the feds pay for that when our
guys drill so the federal government and
the state government are intertwined on
this the situation that the way it is
right now is is really about as good as
you can get it and if you try and
introduce legislation like this first of
all this is this this is now not the
state veterans advisory committee
opinion this is the Kevin Grady opinion
there's no chance on Earth that Governor
sununu signs this bill there's no chance
and the reason for that is that number
one there's only two things about it
that if he signed it that would it would
number one would be you don't understand
how the situation works with the guard
and the active forces and all of that
which he most certainly does or number
two which is worse you know what the
rules are but you choose to
intentionally just disregard them
for reasons that we can't figure out so
you know our guys didn't get as spun up
about this bill as as you would think
that that as maybe that I'm getting spun
up about it a little bit this morning
but
things like this
um and I don't want to use the word
annoy they they they upset veterans
because
the
the system as it works today is is about
as good as you can get it and and
introducing things like this are not
going to to fix that okay uh I apologize
I went over my few minutes uh sir uh
representative baldacero and I now I'll
take questions if or I'll get off the
stage here whichever you'd prefer
thank you Mr chair and thank you Miss
Grady for being here and we do have some
times I I will bring this up I want to
follow up on a point you made about uh
the War Powers Resolution of 1973 in
subsequent uh
uh
response to that by different presidents
uh both President Bush's but
specifically uh president H.W bush in
January of 1991 in fact the uh our chair
was was deployed in the Middle East at
that time and we had around a hundred uh
half and half a million roughly uh
Personnel including
uh Guardsmen reservists in uh theater
Southwest Asia so in January of 1991 the
U.S Senate uh took up as you may recall
uh because of this War Powers Resolution
the authorization used Force which did
pass the Senate very narrowly and then
uh you know Desert Storm commenced
but President Bush 41 uh supposedly
indicated that he had a half million men
and women and service people deployed in
theater
and uh had the U.S Senate not authorized
for us he was going to use Force anyway
that's my understanding and I'm not so
my question is uh what is your
recollection of of that time frame and
and uh had force not been authorized and
the president would have gone ahead and
you know used all this Force to include
uh reservists and Guardsmen
um what would the implications of that
be
um well sir to be honest I I had never
actually heard that story that that the
president was prepared to go ahead uh in
any case I know that at the time I was
flying f-15s on Okinawa and you can't
imagine how unhappy we all were that um
you know we've trained all of our career
I trained at that point of my career for
16 years in case my country needed me
and now I just happened to be stationed
in the wrong theater of operations and
they're you're going to have a war and
you're not going to invite me that was
our that was our attitude on on Okinawa
we were ready to go and we you know we
were told you got to stay home and keep
an eye on North Korea while these other
guys go over and fight the war and to be
sure the air War for people like me that
flew f-15s that were in the air Superior
already role the Iraqi Air Force was
really no match for our air force on
this and they were they were done in
less than a week and after that you know
the f-15c models that I used to fly were
kind of getting in the way you're you're
sort of you're using gas at some Bomb
Dropper really needs up here so but I
had never heard anything like that I
can't imagine that uh that a president
could could survive going against the
will of the Congress like that I just I
started to be honest I've never heard
that story I I don't know what else to
tell you
uh
your theme is great yeah there's no uh
it's it can uh hypothetical question but
it's one that uh some of us have just
always wondered about uh had that forced
resolution not been approved what was
the president going to do with these
half million uh troops and forces uh in
in theater uh so what would happen What
would happen if it was not approved
is then the Congress would have to turn
around via the War Powers Resolution and
say
as of X date you're not allowed to spend
any more money on that
and then those people would have had to
turn around and come home and obviously
they would have had to work out a
deployment schedule in 30 days you're
not going to get it took them from
August when when Kuwait was invaded
until January to get that many forces in
theater and be ready to go so it would
take almost that long I would think to
get those people out of there if the
Congress had said no thank you thank you
are there any other questions uh yes
representative massmail
can you turn your mic
um I was wondering if this bill was
passed
what would the impact of losing a
hundred million dollars be on the
National Guard
that's a question I'm sure we could ask
locally we yeah I'm sure we could ask uh
Colonel Perry behind me is probably
better qualified to answer this than
than I am but
um if if the United States decide if if
the state of New Hampshire decided that
we didn't we didn't want to play by
these rules anymore I believe that the
dod would simply pick up their equipment
and go home they would say we'll we'll
send some Crews to go get those tankers
and we'll give them to someone else
um I I would expect that that would be
what would happen same thing with the
guards uh the the Army National Guard's
equipment you know a senator I mean
Governor sununu didn't write a check for
those Casey 46s okay we those are owned
by the the Department of Defense and
they could move them to any other any
other state that that wanted to you know
abide by the rules that are currently
written as to how we how we operate and
I'm certainly that in short order that
that would happen and then there
wouldn't be any point in having a New
Hampshire Air National Guard without any
air airplanes to fly
thank you you could argue one could
argue we could still keep a small
portion of Army National Guard people
for
natural disasters and things of that
nature but there wouldn't be a need for
uh certainly the need for the Air
National Guard if the if we were to sign
legislation like this
thank you Kevin I of course has a an old
morning here myself and my vice chair we
won't hold it against you on your
service in the Air Force and all that I
appreciate that Mr respect uh you know
your uh testimony here now do you have
written testimony at all no sir okay I I
are there any other questions for
thank you Kevin we appreciate your
testimony
Joe recognize uh Colonel Warren Perry
he's the deputy adjutant General
welcome uh more
thank you Mr chair for the record Warren
Perry Deputy ads in general for New
Hampshire's Department of military
Affairs and veteran services uh I'd like
to start by saying the department
opposes uh House Bill 1092 FN for many
of the reasons that were stated by Mr
Grady
uh most notably is that Congress is
involved when Federal forces or National
Guard forces are federalized uh one of
the things he didn't mention was that in
2001 Congress passed the authorization
to use military forces uh and that bill
that was really contemplated because we
really aren't fighting countries anymore
as we are entities right so we can't
declare war against
Isis for example so they they authorized
the president to to use Force use
military force and as the
commander-in-chief
the president has the authority to
mobilize and federalize the National
Guard of the United States from whatever
state he wants to do that so that's what
we believe so that's really the basis of
our uh of our opposition there are some
other things right so we're not
contemplating whether or not it's
constitutional we don't we don't argue
that uh whether it's constitutional we
do know that Congress is involved
Congress has authorized the use and the
federalization of those forces there are
some court cases pending now about who
has the authority to give orders to the
National Guard is it the governor is it
the secretary of the of defense is it
the secretary of the army or the
secretary of the Air Force and generally
the federal government's winning those
fights
generally not necessarily related to the
use of force in combat but they have the
authority and I think that will bleed
over into those other things
with regard to the impact of funding in
our fiscal note we reckon we we
recognize the risk to the loss of
federal fund right so we didn't say that
the federal government is going to come
down and take away 100 million dollars
we said that funding would be at risk
and certainly it would
so the reason the National Guard is
equipped and manned is because the
federal government sees a need to have a
reserve or a a force that they can reach
into to to continue to close with and
destroy the enemies of the United States
right I mean that's really kind of what
what it is we do
so they man us uh they pay for that
Manning and they pay for our equipment
whether it's helicopters or trucks or
rifles or kc-46 aircraft because the Air
Force guy wants to talk about airplanes
they give us that equipment for that
purpose that those things would go away
now if the if the kc-46 went away would
there be an impact to the state of New
Hampshire
not really because the state of New
Hampshire doesn't use the kc-46 air
refueling tanker but they took away all
our trucks
there would be no PPE delivery in the
state of New Hampshire
so those things that the federal
government gives us that we use to
support the state of New Hampshire would
be at risk
and that's really when we're talking
about you know the potential for 100
million dollars of federal funding to be
impacted that's really what we talk
about
I would like to talk uh addressed a
couple of things I heard just to have
them on the record from the Department
I'm not aware of any other state who has
this legislation passed
the role of the National Guard of New
Hampshire and the National Guard in
general is threefold not twofold we have
a state mission to respond in times of
emergency inside Estates and to other
states when they need it
we have a federal role to fight the
enemies of the United States and protect
our sovereignty
and we build Partnerships we build
Eternal Partnerships we have
Partnerships now established with the
country of El Salvador and now with Cabo
uh not Cabo San Lucas Cabo Verde
so we we have these missions that we we
do and they are not sometimes the lines
blur
as in the federal
resourcing of our response to covid in
the state under title 32 and sometimes
they don't blur like we have people in
the Middle East right now supporting uh
supporting under the
title 10.
next thing I heard was that the governor
can choose whether or not to support or
not support or Direct Federal missions
it's not true he has no authority to
direct any federal Mission zero none
he has he's a force provider and he
doesn't really as a force provider the
governor doesn't have the authority to
say no that's clear in title 10 in the
written testimony that I supplied to the
committee you can see the reference
there I won't go into its legalese I'll
be sure to answer any questions that you
have but it's not an option when the
commander-in-chief of the United States
tells the governor I'm taking your
forces to go to war
with regard to the contemplation of what
would we do if the president of the
United States decides to defy congress's
requirement to have an authorization of
uniform the use of force I would say
it's hypothetical I can't answer the
question but I would say as a as a a
member of the second Army Calvary
regiment
leading the seventh Corps across
the Iraqi and Kuwaiti deserts only took
us a hundred hours so it didn't really
matter right
we really kind of went through that
country relatively quickly now there was
some cleanup that had to go on but the
use of force was relatively quick
right the Air Force and the Marine Corps
and the Navy softened them up real good
for us right so it was about 100 hours
they didn't get much sleep in those
hundred hours but it was
it was very good
so uh that is my testimony and subject
to any questions uh
that is my testimony uh thank you uh
representative deschase in uh if you
could permit Mr chairman could have a
follow-up after my question yes go ahead
thank you thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you Colonel Perry for taking my question
I just want to ask you our national
Guardsmen both federal troops and the
state militia just so we can be very
clear not at the same time but yes so
they have that dual mission right so
they when so I think the best way to
answer your question and and thank you
for the question is they swear two Oaths
when I joined the regular army 1986 I
swore oath to defend the Constitution
United States and obey the orders of the
president
when a Guardsman swears an oath when he
enlists or is commissioned he swears an
oath to defend the Constitution United
States and the president and obey the
president and the constitution of New
Hampshire and the governor so they are
both
but not generally at the same time
okay thank you for clarifying that and
uh follow up Mr chairman
um is a declaration of war needed to
mobilize federal troops in support of
federal missions even if it's an armed
conflict and can you speak to this
specifically as it's addressed towards
the New Hampshire National Guard so the
answer is the president has the
authority to federalize the National
Guard
when he sees fit title 10 makes that
very clear so if you look at the written
testimony that and I can read the
passage there but it's in there I don't
think I need to read it to you I read it
so so the answer is yes the short answer
to your question is yes the president
doesn't need the governor's permission
to do that without a declaration of war
Congress in our our opinion right and
we're not debating the constitutionality
of the authorization for the use of
military force the War Powers Act we're
not debating that at all Congress has
given the president the authority to
mobilize the the federal forces the
state forces the reserves for armed
conflict they have so the answer the
short answer is yes I think I've
answered your question but I may not
have uh I think you did too thank you
Colonel Perry
thank you any other questions on this
side uh representative Perez thank you
for that for the time thank you for
taking my my question uh Colonel Perry
um I
I want to hear a little bit more I'm
from El Salvador and you mentioned in
something from El Salvador and I didn't
really pay attention to it and I just
wanted like you to like tell me exactly
what our celebrity is doing
so the the National Guard has a program
in conjunction with the state department
the U.S Department of State
and the combatant commanders so we have
a Central Command Commander that deals
with Central America we have a a South
I'm sorry a South Comp Commander that
deals with Central Command deals with uh
with the Middle East generally africom
so these Regional commanders so in
conjunction with these Regional
combatant Commanders and the U.S
Department of State the National Guard
establishes a state partnership program
and different National Guards have
programs with different states we have a
program with El Salvador and we have had
that program for some number of years
it's flourishing I'd be happy to await
you know since it's non-germaine to this
bill I'd be happy to talk to you in a
break or and get you any other
information
are there any other questions over there
I had a couple for you there um
can you explain to the committee here
like um I mean I know we brought up
about the KC 46 is what happens to like
I think the planes that go up the coast
there that God certain areas are when
they're activated to fly like what
happened when on 9 11 when the you know
they were planes up in a year who would
refuel those aircraft I mean is in that
part of your mission so the the the the
157th air refueling Wing has their
mission is aerial refueling uh their
primary Mission they generally fly every
day in support of the air bridge over
the North Atlantic so they're generally
refueling somebody
you know going between here and Europe
every day okay so so if there's
something going on they're going to
mobilize those aircraft to get them in
the air to keep to keep the combat the
combatant aircraft in the area my my
other question so the committee
understands and knows how many
um federal employees you have that
federal employees during the week
working and on the weekend one week in a
month they put the uniform on so the
guard has so there are about uh I think
it's about I don't have the numbers off
top of my head I'm sorry I'm Rusty so
I'm going to give you approximate
numbers please bear with me there are
about a thousand air Guardsmen right and
there are about 1700 Army Guardsmen all
of those folks that wear a uniform all
of them whether they're one they're
weakened or we call them traditional
drilling reservists or drilling
Guardsmen or they're full-time and they
can be in a couple of statuses they can
be in an active Garden Reserve status
they can be a title 32 technician status
all of them that wear a uniform receive
their pay from the federal government
all of them none of them now there are
the only two people that work directly
for the state every day uh or me and the
edge in general and the engine generals
only in the military on this week my
last question for the committee just so
you understand and I've been on this
committee for 15 years and one of my uh
the best chairman I've ever had in this
committee was representative Chris
Roberts here who was retired Marine
lieutenant colonel we served in the
Marines together and he was one of the
did his homework and he actually I was
reading a write-up on him back in 2008
but anyways is Chris still serves
veterans right yes he's doing a great
job helping them and Chris was a
Democrat and him and I worked hand in
hand in many bills so is Democrat Anna
marine and you still like it right yeah
I don't I don't hold I don't hold it
against them you know but he he's uh
honorable honorable guy one of the best
I've ever met but anyways my question is
basically for you to answer for the
committee is on the um
geez now I lost where I was going with
this here on on The Bachelor that you
have uh that activate
at any given time you only deploy
50 is that still correct or uh maintain
a force to maintain for emergencies no
no that that's not necessarily true so
we we deploy our soldiers based on the
combatant Commander's need so if they
need forces and we have them and we get
tasks to deploy them we will deploy them
right so there is no ratio for us
whether or not we're gonna we're only
gonna deploy 50 this week and 50 that
week historically historically our
deployments have been less than 50 of
our total Force historically they have
been less than 50 percent of our total
force and I think deployments are going
to continue to be
less right not more less and less you
know unless there's unless some other
contingency comes up we're gonna we're
gonna be pretty pretty pretty pretty
level or less in our numbers of
deployments uh
yes sir I think that should answer your
question yeah that does answer I just
wanted to clarify something on that yeah
thank you are there any other questions
thank you for coming here and I
appreciate you uh making life a little
easier on sending us your
um write-ups on different bills and very
a lot of work you put into them yes and
thank you and thank you for the work the
committee does on behalf of veterans
that stay in New Hampshire thank you
okay we don't have any more nope okay
with that I'm going to close
um House Bill 1092 and the next one is
at 10 30 I think
okay
you notice I don't pick on the army of
the Air Force too bad I try to go easy
on them
my husband would appreciate that yeah
okay
oh six is established
1106.
um
Warren are you speaking are you going to
speak on the recruitment at all on 1106
you have somebody that's going to
explain as things
okay because
okay good because the reason I'm asking
because I only have two cards on this
next bill and I think it's very
important so I'm going to explain what
you're already doing and what we've done
in the past
yeah
wait here let me uh
let me see
that was 10 32 right 1092 rather
but it's not changing the name of the
day yeah it's uh calling it remembrance
a in a proclamation there for that day
Veterans Day is designed for those
Veterans of living
Memorial Day is designed for those that
made the ultimate sacrifice all right so
we can't do that one yeah
yeah that's the only ones
hey that's it
because we only did two bills
we only did two bills we're on our third
yeah I mean I love Steve Charlotte but
the thing is the change is back to
Remembrance Day world but it's not
yeah well he's he's wants a proclamation
call and Remembrance Day in New
Hampshire so that's changing it
30 pyramid
all right now 10 31.
I'm going to open up the hearing on
House Bill
1106 establishing a committee to study
recruiting certain members of the Armed
Forces and I am going to welcome
representative lasalles
to testify
welcome representative member of the
committee
thank you chairman baldacero and uh Vice
chairman moffatt and The Honorable
members other honorable members of
the committee
and also besides honorable members we
have
Dr Lundgren here today so that's it's
good to have him too
my my idea on this bill
is that I think
people that are coming out of the
service
no matter which branch and no matter how
long they've been in the service
have skills
that really fit in with
what we have or not a need for here in
New Hampshire
and
I think that New Hampshire has a great
story to be told
that the people that are in the service
would look to New Hampshire as a very
favorable place
to relocate
um
the if a person is getting out of the
service depending on how long they've
been in
they
have really three choices
to relocate to they can relocate back to
their home of our origin
they can stay where they are maybe they
have Roots now
if they get out of the Navy in Norfolk
perhaps they have a job that they can go
to or they can go to a completely
different place
and I really want to Target
those people
who are either
native to New Hampshire or they're
looking for a place to resettle to move
their family
and I use myself as a
as an example of someone
I joined the Navy off the farm in the
Midwest
I didn't have a lot of
possibilities there
I was not I lived on a farm but I really
didn't like to be a farmer
I joined the Navy and spent 10 years in
the submarine service
and before I went in I talked to a
recruiter and I said
what should I go into in the Navy
uh and he said one of two things either
go into computers or nuclear power
now this was in 1969
and I had I couldn't even spell computer
I had no idea what nuclear power was
but I ended up getting involved in both
of those because I served on nuclear
submarines I got out after 10 years
with a lot of really good experience and
I could have relocated anywhere in the
country
and I really did not want to go back to
Illinois and I didn't want to stay where
I was
so I got a job at Wang labs in Lowell
Mass
and I didn't want to live in
Massachusetts at that time it was called
taxa juices
and that was in 1979 so I spent 10 years
in the service so I moved to New
Hampshire and have lived in Litchfield
which I represent here ever since
and I feel as if I have died and gone to
heaven
now the idea
like I said before
is that I feel that New Hampshire really
has a good story to be told
and there's a lot of people
in the service who would love to
relocate to this state
I don't know if any of you are fans of a
of an Animal Planet show called
Northwoods law any of you seen
Northwoods law Northwoods law I think
is like the New Hampshire Chamber of
Commerce it really puts New Hampshire in
good light
I have talked to a number of people and
I say we should be advertising on
northwood's law because somebody that's
watching that now not everybody but some
a lot of people who watch that say wow
what a nice place
it's not only beautiful and it has all
kinds of things to offer but the people
are nice too
and so my idea
is that we need to get our story out
we need to Market New Hampshire
now as I've gotten into this I have
learned
that in almost every military
installation there's a group there's a
function
that assists people that are getting out
to
you know they're getting out of the
service to prepare them for getting out
that wasn't the case when when I got out
but
what I'd like to do is to have some sort
of presence
in as many of those places as possible
that tells the New Hampshire story
um with with respect to
skills that I think we should be looking
for it's not it's not concentrated in
either the public sector or the private
sector both can make use of this
and I think when legislative Services
put this together
they sort of said certain certain
members of of the service
I'm not restricting I I don't wish to
restrict it to anybody but I must say
that here in New Hampshire
we are not a very diverse community
you know we're almost all white let's
face it
and I was
I was
alarmed
when the former police chief in Nashua a
friend of mine
told me in the city of Nashville almost
a hundred thousand people that is a
fairly diverse community
there is there wasn't at least at that
point and that was only like a couple of
years ago there were zero
African-American police
on the force
now
I believe in in
hiring the best person for the job but
We should strive
for the police force to reflect the
community that they serve
and you know we should have black and
brown members
of certainly Nashua and Manchester the
State Police in almost every case
there there are very few members
that are people of color
and I think that's a problem
so what I would say
is
the service people
expands our Horizons
with respect to who we're recruiting
there are military police
in the in the forces Air Forces the
Marines the Army and so forth and
certainly there's a lot of those folks
that are people of color
and I would love to for them to consider
New Hampshire as a place to to
uh resettle to
and I think that would be a great thing
with respect to health care workers
I mean with this coven thing it really
has put them magnifying glass but in
almost every sector both private and
public
we are in real need for
people to come here now we have other
issues with respect to housing and so
forth I'm not touching that but
the goal of this is to figure out how
the state of New Hampshire
can
get our story out there the Live Free or
Die story needs to be in front of every
single veteran
who leaves
the service
that story needs to be there and they
might maybe they watched northwood's law
and maybe they said wow what a nice
place to live and play and work
and if we had our story out there
I think that we could recruit that and
from from our standpoint
having veterans in New Hampshire
New Hampshire is a veteran friendly
place we have a high per capita if it's
not one of the if it's not the greatest
number of veterans in the State uh we're
very close to it
and we have a veteran I've been talking
with Amy who I believe is going to
testify
we have a
the business Community is very veteran
friendly
and uh
so I I think it's uh it's a true
win-win-win situation
so with that I'll be happy to take any
questions that you might have
thank you representative
um your testimony do you have any
written testimony or is it just speak
from the heart like I do
it's up here we're uh
okay will you take questions sure
representative
thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
representative for your testimony I'm
somebody who also has moved here and
fallen in love with this state and my
brother-in-law who is uh who is the air
force uh veteran also with loves and
would love to move up here he lives in
Long Island so but he would love to move
up here my question is
um with respects to young people and
like you know especially Young Young
Veterans who you know want to relocate
and start you know they just came out of
the service and they just want to start
a new have you talked to maybe like stay
work play who is an organ that's an
organization that you know tries to help
retain young people in the state about
uh possibly like their interest in this
committee um because I think I think
their knowledge would be certainly be
helpful have you talked to them I have
not taught I'm aware of that there is
such a committee uh but I I have not
talked to them personally but if I may
ask I'd like to turn the tables where
were you from originally
um go ahead I'll let that go we're not
we want to move along things originally
from Orange County California so okay I
spent a lot of time there's a marine El
Toro and Tustin but uh okay
um any other questions
um yes representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative uh for taking my question
thanks for your testimony thanks for
your service to our country
um I'm wondering if you have considered
uh this as this legislation to be a
commission uh where you could bring
stakeholders from across the state from
higher ed from private business from the
state of New Hampshire together to
develop the strategies if I may uh
interject you we're going to have Amy
that's going to be coming up who runs
the program and she will probably be
able to answer that question better on
uh whether Commission on whether the
study is beneficial for the uh National
Guard that we have here so I'd hold that
question until uh she comes up
any other yes go ahead can I just follow
up and I guess the reason that I that I
bring this up is uh we developed a
bipartisan commission uh in the last
legislative session uh focused on
attracting and retaining civilian
national service members through
Americorps and the Peace Corps some of
those recommendations are being
introduced as legislation this year
um and would be happy to share some of
our findings and strategies because I
think that the kind of service driven
community-minded young people to help
power our Workforce into the future is
something that crosses military and
civilian national service lines and I
think there's a lot of opportunity to
collaborate and learn from each other
thanks thank you any other questions
representative Chase
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question uh representative
I was wondering have you spoken with the
New Hampshire Department of Labor
regarding what they might be doing
already to to um to have this process
going I haven't I I know there are
various things in place
and I haven't spoken spoken to the
Department of Labor but one of the
things that I anticipate is that we have
to figure out what is already in place
so that we don't reinvent the wheel
but I have not spoken to the Department
of Labor okay thank you
um representative thank you Mr follow up
on representative this year's question
by the way thank you for being here
representative shells and this is an
area where we need workers and so this
is a great topic my question is similar
to his uh and maybe the next speaker
could touch on this but uh have you been
in touch with anyone from the Department
of resources and economic development
the only thing I've done there
as I fired off an email saying why
aren't we advertising on northwood's law
the only thing I've done
thank you thank you any other questions
uh representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking me a question
um in the bill it says you know that you
were going to look at offering
incentives by employers to
offer incentives to employers for hiring
vets do you have any examples of what
might be an incentive
um
the the idea that I have but all of this
has to be developed through the
commission but is to provide incentives
such in the in the area of Education or
I can Envision someone uh getting a
break with respect to their tuition I I
know that representative baltazaro has
said that we now allow State uh our
in-state tuition to the state uh you
know I I would like to see incentives in
that way working with employers I know
Amy's going to speak about some of the
things that employers are currently
doing in the way of incentives but
whatever makes economic sense to me
would be good thank you I represent
Perez before you go if I may just keep
in mind the duty experts going to be
coming up in a few minutes which will be
Amy after Kevin Grady and she's she's
going to advise and let you know what
we've been doing and how this is working
and why this is a win-win there's bill
for the state and that would help out so
keep that in mind because it's we got
about 12 more minutes and we want to
move along but go ahead representative
yes uh thank you for uh for taking my
question my question to you is and your
testimony money you say that we need
more diversity in New Hampshire
how do you see this bill or this
committee helping us to bring more
diversity into New Hampshire
we you know we we know we that we have a
lot of people they wanted to move here
uh with uh different backgrounds and
different cultures and how do you see
this bill helping us to bring more of
these more of the people to divert New
Hampshire here okay thank you very much
for the for the question a couple of
different ways one we expand the pool
all right if we restrict ourselves to
only people who have lived here for 20
years you're not going to have a lot but
if we expand the pool we will get more
and the second thing is I'm trying to
figure out how we can get the ethnic
churches involved okay because there
there is a very active uh
religious community on the ethnic side
if we could get them involved then I
think that would be good
follow-up if I can
um um I'm more than inhabited at 202 to
to work with you as well I'm the chair
of the Latino caucus and you know we
have some information and maybe you have
some information that it can help us as
well okay
thank you thank you are there any other
questions
I I thank you representative uh Joe uh
recognize Kevin Grady
who supports the bill from the svac
thank you Mr chairman
ladies and gentlemen the committee once
again for the record my name is Kevin
Grady 25-year Air Force veteran 22-year
veteran of Hooksett I'm here
representing the state veterans advisory
committee and thank heavens a bill we
support we support this one it will be
supporting a few more that you'll hear
today as well but we do support this
bill the only thing and and I don't want
to take too much time away from the
experts are going to testify after me
but the only thing that we saw in this
bill is it the title it says recruit
certain veterans
and that the implication there is we'd
like these veterans but these veterans
over here not so much
um so we'd like to have you take the
word certain out of there and just say
recruit veterans and if if the committee
that you put together wants to Target
certain communities for certain skill
sets that we need in New Hampshire
that's all great but but the idea is we
are a veteran friendly State and that
that word needs to get out and that's
really a subject to your questions
that's all I wanted to say all right
thank you on your recommendation there
so the committee knows I have an
amendment being joined Christine is
already sent downstairs for an amendment
on this bill that's going to also add a
couple more people to the bill okay from
the National Garden and also from the
state veterans advisory committee so
there is an amendment being drafted in
the word taken out as you asked
requested thank you sir okay uh any
questions for Kevin Grady
thank you none thank you uh the chill
recognized uh Amy Cook from the
Department of military Affairs and
Veterans Services who does an
outstanding job on behalf of the
veterans here in the state and welcome
Amy
sorrow chairman Moffett and honorable
members of the committee I did submit
for the record my name is Amy Cook I'm
the administrator of the division of
community-based military programs at the
New Hampshire Department of military
Affairs and Veterans Services I did
submit some written testimony and I'm
going to take just a minute to read
through it because I think it sets the
stage for my follow-up thoughts that I
think will also answer some of the
questions you previously had
the department of military Affairs and
Veterans Services is in support of House
Bill 1106 in July of 2020 House Bill
1582 was signed into law this requires
the department of military Affairs and
Veterans Services to do three things
number one promote existing military
skills test waiver programs available in
the state number two work with the
office of professional licensure and
certification to conduct a review of all
state licenses for which military
veterans may have relevant training or
experience and identify any steps that
can be taken without further legislation
to develop and promote these
opportunities and number three develop
recommendations and proposed legislation
designed to increase the acceptance of
military training and experience towards
professional licensing
the position created by the department
of military Affairs and veteran services
to be responsible for these requirements
was just recently filled in December
2021 December 3rd to be exact the
department has taken action to start
meeting the requirements set in House
Bill 1582 and has determined that there
are potentially a great number of
opportunities in the state to increase
the acceptance of military training and
experience towards Professional
Licensing a legislatively established
committee could help prioritize these
opportunities that exist and provide
input regarding the development of those
that could also exist in the future the
department of military Affairs and
Veterans Services would like to request
representation on the committee
established to study recruiting former
members of the Armed Forces two job
opportunities within the state and
obviously would welcome the opportunity
to provide input to the committee we
respectfully ask that the committee
considers supporting this bill
we have so off the Record so the part
that's not in the written testimony is
that even in just a few three weeks
since the new position was filled we've
taken a lot of different steps to
start the framework for this talking
with people around the state about what
exists already what exists nationally
that we could bring to New Hampshire how
to promote that there's some things that
exist that people don't know exist and
it's hard to find information on the
internet about so taking all of that
promoting it better educating people
about those opportunities and then
really starting to look at where could
we fill some gaps in the different
Workforce sectors that we have we also
in July summer of 2020 we launched the
New Hampshire veteran friendly business
Network along with New Hampshire
employment security and we have almost
60 businesses that are recognized as
veteran friendly businesses in New
Hampshire so we're growing that Network
they meet quarterly they are super
engaged and passionate about recruiting
people into the state of New Hampshire
so they're now meeting there's a work
group meeting bi-weekly twice a month to
talk about a national recruit campaign
where they might want to put some
efforts and resources of their own from
their own business into
bringing people from California here
bringing people from Alaska here Hawaii
Virginia to choose New Hampshire as
their home so and stay work play was top
of my list for you know reaching out
because they've done an amazing job of
doing just that we're partnering with
the business and economic Affairs
department travel and tourism they are
in middle of strategic planning for a
similar effort to bring Workforce from
other states here so we're going to be
partnering with them I have a meeting
scheduled next week to talk about where
we might overlap and align our efforts
and kind of take the Synergy into the
same direction
so pending any questions that's my
testimony thank you well thank you Amy
um you know a few years ago I passed I
sponsored legislation on uh with the
yellow ribbon program on any veterans
from around the country coming into the
state once they get an apartment they
automatically qualify as a resident and
they get in-state tuition at our
universities have you heard getting
feedback on how that is working on
attracting veterans and are they coming
in
I don't have information about how
that's working that's kind of out of my
field that I focus on however it's
definitely been in my mind that as we go
through this National recruitment
campaign those are the types of things
that we want to highlight you know
because they those types of benefits
um not just why New Hampshire is a great
place but why it's a great place for you
as a military family you as someone
transitioning out of the military to
come to New Hampshire okay another
question here and I'm only asking these
questions for the benefit of new veteran
new reps that are on the committee here
we passed legislation also a while ago
on licensing and credentialing you
brought that up and we're and we also
have which I sponsored we also added in
spouses that are moving into the state
have you does that helped at all on the
recruitment in other areas there for
veterans coming in to maybe join the
National Guard yes so one of the great
benefits of that a pause positive
outcome of that is that it certainly
brought it to the Forefront in
conversations so in the New Hampshire
veteran friendly business Network that
we have we're often talking about it's
not just the veteran you know we want to
come live here we want their entire
family to be employed here as well
Service Credit Union is one of the
businesses that we work with and after
discussing that in the beginning they
shared with us that that prompted them
to have discussions at their business
about how to bring more military spouses
into their Workforce and so they've
created a whole entire strategic plan
around doing that so it's definitely
it brought the conversation forward and
it's been highlighted in a lot of
different ways so I think that there are
some results that are now starting to
happen from that outstanding thank you
uh any other questions remember
representative deschase I was just
wondering how well thank you for taking
my question thank you Mr chairman for
recognizing me how close is your office
and your department work with the
community college system of New
Hampshire to upskiller reskill workers
and
um would your department be you know
hopefully in the future continuing that
effort and maybe concentrating more on a
you know re retooling and reskilling
Veterans coming to this state thank you
yes so they're definitely
part of that puzzle right like they're a
puzzle piece to that entire conversation
so as the staff who we've just hired
who's starting starting to sift through
what opportunities are out there
um and does and figure out what else do
we want to do they're going to be a
major piece of that conversation because
there's a lot of opportunities there
that exist already and can be promoted
through all of this but I think that
they also hold a key to things that can
continue to be developed
yeah
thank you
um Amy um something that popped to my
head right now we put in a line item uh
for retention and helping veterans uh
National Guard to 25
000 line item is that still there that
didn't get taken out of the budget I'm
open Warren nod yes or no is that money
still there for the veterans
okay good and the reason
for I mean for National God I'm right so
my question is and I haven't seen a
board I thought I was on that board and
I haven't we haven't had one in a while
is that coming forward
okay I just wanted because that was
another tool that we did for retention
to help and with recruitment well and
that'll definitely be the idea of
National Guard right so that'll be one
of those
Espionage National recruitment campaign
is as we're asking people to come here
you know also think about serving in the
National Guard when you come here you
know if you're at a point in your life
when you're you still want to serve you
still can serve and you have interest in
doing that that'll be one of those
puzzle pieces that will attach thank you
any other questions from the committee
Mr chair oh I'm sorry representative
Foster
thank you Mr chair
um
and thank you for taking the question
when I got out of the service and and
got out of the Air Force
um they had a a transitional assistance
program or taps and they they sent us
there and we went through and there was
a lot of businesses and a lot of of
different Flyers that were presented to
us do we have anything going right now
with the active duty military branches
to get our information into those Taps
programs so that we have good
communication of hey here we are and and
maybe you'd like to think about coming
here the seeds have been planted
so yes we have started talking with them
and to my knowledge
um just like you said that there's
businesses that are that get into that
but to my knowledge I believe we're
going to be the first state to have a
Statewide effort
um through Taps through some other
programs that are out there to the
Chamber of Commerce Hiring Our Heroes
program that goes around the country
um we're again to my knowledge we're
going to be the first state that has
sort of this campaign packaged campaign
with videos workshops some live sessions
on the internet for people to tap into
and learn about New Hampshire so and
we're going to call you know something
something like why New Hampshire and
then break it down into a lot of
different reasons because there's a
hundred reasons why New Hampshire so yes
the seeds have been planted thank you
you're welcome well thank you I don't
see any more questions Amy I want to
thank you very much and compliment you
on the great work you do for the
veterans here in the state of New
Hampshire not only just a National Guard
because you're also helping other
branches of the service there which is a
win-win fall so thank you thank you and
with that I want to close HB 1106 and
we're going to go right into
um
give me one second here that might make
sure my clerk is ready
house built 1256 which is relative to a
position within the department of
military fears and Veterans Services
is representative Allied here
you'll see
okay
you'll introduce the bill okay
at 12 56.
representative deshays is going to
introduce the bill for representative
Allen
long address
I always say Warren Perry for last thank
you
well he's
Warren I already had a card on you
yeah
okay uh representative Chase Floyd yours
thank you Mr chairman and thank you to
the rest of my colleagues for for
entertaining me this morning so um
representative Allard couldn't make it
this morning
um he uh sadly has come down with uh
copen19 he sent a letter to the
committee I believe last night
um explaining what the purpose of this
legislation is so I'm just going to read
his letter into the record
um he he explains it much better and can
do it better Justice than I ever could
and it's very important to um him
personally I believe his father served
and helped run this Cemetery after his
father left active service duty if I'm
not mistaken so for representative Valor
this is a very um this Veteran Cemetery
in New Hampshire is a uh one of the best
run in the country it's very important
to him and it's important to Veterans
across the state so uh I'll continue and
read his uh letter so from
representative Allard Mr chairman and
colleagues due to a positive covid test
Following last week's full session I was
I will be unable to be with you for the
hearings scheduled for the 14th I was
supposed to introduce House Bill 1256
instead representative Terry Roy is
expected to introduce the bill
if something unforeseen detains reproy
then rep Brody deshays will step in to
make the introduction both reps are
co-sponsors of the bill House Bill 1256
was initiated at the request of the
Edgerton General's office and is an
appropriate step forward for the
Department of military Affairs and the
New Hampshire veterans cemetery our
Veteran Cemetery is an icon among
similar facilities around the country it
is a source of justifiable pride in New
Hampshire and of great comfort to
families of deceased veterans House Bill
1256 establishes a framework for taking
that facility forward and for
recognizing the contributions of the
dedicated and accomplished Workforce we
are so fortunate to to employ there
please accept my apologies for being
unable to be with you for the hearing
suffice it to say you are all better off
if I remain sequestered at home for a
few more days this is an important bill
and I hope you will be able to advance
it quickly to the Full House thank you
respectfully representative J.C Ellard
uh Pittsburgh pits Pittsfield and epsom
and um with that I think the adjutant
general can probably do better Justice
than me to explain all the changes
within this bill it's a pretty long bill
it's kind of broken down into three
parts by the office of legislative
services so I will not yield to any
questions okay thank you uh
representative I agree with you there
thank you Mr chairman did you recognize
um
Kevin Grady for a quick uh support the
bill from the svac and then we'll go
right into Warren
thank you Mr chairman once again for the
record Kevin Grady uh 25-year Air Force
veteran 23-year resident of Hooksett New
Hampshire representing the state
veterans advisory committee
um we unanimously support this bill to
be honest with all of you we were
frankly shocked that these folks were
not on a salary but were in fact hourly
wage earners when we found out that uh
Sean buck and Amy Cook were were in fact
in that in that other category to speak
just from my personal experience I know
that that Sean Buck out at the cemetery
works a lot of Saturdays because I was
there with him on a Saturday back in
November when my Association of
graduates of the Air Force Academy group
went out there and and cleaned
gravestones and he was out there with a
few of his folks in the morning
um and I I've also seen
uh Amy Cook at our state veterans
advisory committee giving testimony all
of these kind of things fall outside the
normal nine to five office hours and we
think it is in fact appropriate to put
these people on a salary instead of an
hour hourly wage and again that's that's
all I want to say is that we've active
we've enthusiastically support this and
Colonel Perry can get down into the nuts
and bolts of what needs to happen
thank you uh Kevin are there any
questions uh
I thank you very much sir with that I
welcome once again uh Deputy adjun
General Warren Perry
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee again for the record Warren
Perry Deputy Edge and General New
Hampshire's Department of military
Affairs and Veterans Services the
department clearly supports the bill
since we requested that uh
representative Roy representative Allard
and uh the esteemed colleague from this
morning here are sponsoring uh
sponsoring the legislation really what
this gets to is two things from our
perspective I provided some written
testimony in advance via email that you
may have seen and I've just given the
clerk copies to distribute but two
things really the first thing is
in the the state's personal
classification system the hourly wage
and punching a Time Clock system is not
very Nimble it's it's really very rigid
and both Amy Cook who is the
administrator for community-based
military programs who you heard a little
earlier today and Sean Buck who directs
the cemetery work a lot a ton of off
schedule hours
so that requires an administrative
burden for us to be able to manage comp
time over time making sure that time
cards are correct and it's not really
commensurate with their duties they're
Bound by this time clock when they
really should be free away from the time
clock to be able to perform their duties
so that's the first thing
the second thing is uh in 2000 uh
RSA 110b was amended to create the
department of military Affairs and
veteran services from what was then the
adjutant generals Department The Edge
and Generals Department really had the
cemetery and the military Affairs piece
when we assumed the responsibility to
administer in the department the rest of
the Veterans Affairs piece
we received Amy's division from the
Department of Health and Human Services
and we we took control of the division
then the office of veteran services now
the division of Veterans Services
at the time we did that the director of
the division Veterans Services was in
the unclassified system so now we have
three directors essentially one in the
classified system or two in the
classified system and one in the
unclassified system and the pay is not
necessarily
equal not that it would necessarily
always be equal but it's not necessarily
commensurate so what this bill does
really is it moves those two key
positions uh the administrator for uh
division of community-based military
programs and the cemetery director into
the unclassified position creates parity
in the department for our division
directors in terms of their work
schedules and closer to their pay we
won't know that until we get through the
entire process and it allows the
adjutant general and me to administer
veterans programs
flexibly
subject to your questions that concludes
my testimony
thank you are there any uh questions
okay this this here for the committee is
an early build and I have a couple of
questions on the finance idea
because this bill more likely will be
going to finance I think it has to go
also to the Joint Committee on the Edna
yeah you know as you go to Joint
Committee on employee classification as
well yeah I don't know but I just know
it's an early bill right and when it had
when it has an FN normally you know
Finance
okay my question is on a salary like for
instance uh when this passes I guess
it'll be effective in uh fiscal year
2023 right but uh 48 000 what does that
mean so the 48 000 includes the payoff
to to because there will be there are
benefits earned that when they leave the
classified system have to be paid out so
that calculates not only the increase in
salary but also the cost of the payout
for benefits okay so there is an
increase in I I take it in anticipation
in anticipate so the fiscal note that
the department wrote was based on where
we thought that the position would fall
in the unclassified position so
commensurate with what uh what the
division of veteran services has we
figured that would be in the CC band of
the unclassified system which starts at
step one at about 61 000 and ends at
step seven at about 84 000.
so we uh we anticipated somewhere around
step four in that system but that won't
be determined until a study is done with
a recommendation of where that falls so
our estimate is based on that so I take
it that fiscal year 22 budget distance
right okay I was just wondering what
that cost I'm sorry I didn't mean to get
into the nuts and bolts I thought that's
where you're going but it's but no
that's what I wanted to understand here
so in case I'm asked from Finance or
someone else you know that I I got an
idea because I'll have to brief the bill
right and I know where I'm going okay
are there any other questions uh
okay uh thank you uh thank you again for
hearing my testimony
and uh in about two minutes or so we're
going to exec this bill and then a
couple other bills there and get them
out of the way so it'll be less we got
to do on next Friday
um
so give it give us a minute for
representative to talk with
I'm going to close the hearing on 1256
sorry about that
yeah that's fine yeah
I'm gonna I need to go talk to our
um committee assistant the committee
assistant because I'm going to need to
get those the uh okay yeah
pages
foreign
I know
I'm going to open up executive uh
session on HB 1256 and representative
shows you have a motion
thank you Mr chairman I'd like the
motion ought to pass on House Bill 1256.
okay there's a motion to ought to pass
on 1256 and uh representative Moffat you
had a second I thought
I do second that Mr chair thank you uh
with that is uh would you like to
discuss anything on the uh your motion
at all uh I don't think I don't think
it's necessary I think we hashed out
everything during the public hearing
okay thank you does anyone else like to
discuss on 1256
this is an early build and
no everyone's all set oh you have a
question yes just the comment just want
to say like appreciate the hard work
that Amy and the other folks are doing
and hopefully they get paid you know or
have the get transferred into a pay
grade that will be flexible for them so
that they can keep doing stuff on the
off hours awesome thank you uh anyone
else
um uh with that I'm going to ask the
clerk to um go to a roll call
hi
yes
no I'm sorry uh
representative Foster
yes
representative
amila
no problem
yes
representative labranche
yes representative Lofton
yes did I did I correct correct did I
get that pronunciation correct you did
thank you
and representative wilkowitz
yes
and representative Val deserro yes
what's the number one uh
16 years with no Nays 16.
okay the vote is 16-0 uh without any
doubt I will put it on the consent
calendar
okay
consent
so I'll post a hearing on 1256. do we
need it we don't need a majority report
uh yes the majority report will have to
be done give it to um
give me one second we'll catch up here
with the next one will be um
um yeah 1092.
thank you
1106 we can't do until we get the
amendment
um
oh you all set I'm waiting on you yep
okay 16 is zero okay
I'm gonna open up the hearing on
[Music]
and
who did I say was going to make the
motion oh I I will make the motion to uh
itl
I'll second that
did that Russian national thank you
okay and I'll speak to my motion
1092 is
um it although feels good sounds good uh
it's the wrong bill for today's society
for the military uh it's a come to us
this I think before the fifth time it's
been towards here therefore it makes no
sense to move forward because it's not
going to happen so let's just go to the
vote and if anyone else has anything to
add to it
nobody okay then I'll ask the click to
go to the vote
uh yes on the itl motion okay
representative Lundgren yes
representative
Rollins yes
representative yes uh representative
Foster
no on itl
okay and representative Deshay
uh yes on the ought to pass motion no
it's an Ito yes on the itl motion my
apologies I'm filling out the committee
report
uh
representative massamila
okay
and representative Piedra yes
representative Perez
okay yes
uh and representative Wilhelm yes
representative espia yes
representative
toll yeah
Representative labranche no
yes on the itl yes on Ito and
representative wilkowitz yes
okay me so we've got two and then me oh
I do that every time pardon me uh
representative yes on the itl
okay
14 years
14-2 okay well will there be a um
Minority Report on this bill yeah
huh
you're gonna write okay labret okay uh
we'll give you if we're done you'll give
you a sheet here to fill out so we can
get that done right here
um okay and I will do the majority
okay with that I'm going to close to
here in a 1092 which was a itl 14 or two
any problems on putting it on the
consent or you want it on
on the consent do you plan on fighting
us on the floor I do not tell you we
have any problems with on the consent
calendar
okay it'll be on the consent calendar
thank you
okay what we'll do is we'll take a early
lunch I cannot
um
do the exec on the um
1106 yet until I get the amendment so
we'll do that sometime this afternoon uh
you know in between bills that we have
but I want to thank you all there and
coming forward this will make it easier
when we come back in Next Friday with
less bills that we got to mess with
thank you
one o'clock yes
and I found out the cafeteria is open if
anyone was questioning that
okay not bad yeah
okay awesome so this can go oh thank you
thank you
foreign
yeah I thought
yep I got one and Mike got one you
actually need two of them
one for you and one for the record
uh 1362.
uh well um representative Susan uh
dilemmas is passing out the amendment
for HP 1106 the one that we were talking
about earlier I'm going to open up the
hearing
on um
and then
on 1362 and I'll need a pink card from
you when you're done and I'll welcome
the sponsor
let me get to my bill here
representative Roy
um to speak on the bill related to the
authority of the state God
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is representative
Terry Roy I represent Rockingham 32.
I'm here today for your consideration to
Bill authorizing the state guard
um
when I wrote this bill after speaking
with many other members of the House
we had an interest in somehow allowing
veterans who who have separated from
service and other form of law
enforcement to be able to use their
training experience and to continue to
contribute and help
help the members of the the citizens of
New Hampshire
in some capacity since Drafting and
submitting the bill I've spoken to
several members of the State National
Guard and state veterans organizations
and they explained to me that while this
is a good idea the way it's written
um would be very expensive and they're
they couldn't support it
so after having that discussion with
them they did agree to speak to me and
work with me on somehow coming up with a
feasible program that we would be able
to put that experience and training to
use so we're going to continue to work
on that and based on that
um I'm in the ironic position of asking
you to itl my own bill
and save you some time
this is a lot a bill that I've supported
a while ago long time in
and I honestly believe that we should
have something in but as this keeps
coming forward I learn more and more
what goes on in the state like in my
town we have what you call alert team in
other towns they have these teams that
like that go out and they're trained and
you know Medical in carrying
um
you know emergency getting people out of
the woods and things uh the alert team
in my which is now called the uh I'm
trying to think of what they call it now
but anyways
emergency response yeah and they trained
on going out and they've gone out on
searches out in the mountains and other
stuff and in the woods for lost kids and
other things there they're called upon
each City's entire many cities and towns
are already maintaining names and
numbers so I learned a lot here and I
know the National Guard has already over
and over said they don't have the time
to maintain lists I'll do the training
or go through the Surplus because we
were questioning on the uniforms and
other things there or organization I'm
bringing this up so the committee
understands what's been going on for a
long time here with this here I mean in
the Constitution talks about on the
militia it goes into it we do have
legislation a law is already on the
books on this here you know the militia
but just get it over the hurdle to move
forward with it the support's just not
there and I and I see it because it has
been coming to me many times you know
here so I respect that I was going to do
an interim study there but you requested
an Ito then I'd go with that and uh yeah
there's no shame in admitting that your
bill just isn't working well and I admit
this isn't workable at this time I mean
I wish there's something because during
disasters it's a no-brainer especially
if our national God is deployed and you
know it offsets and helps out and we're
but I I keep hearing from communities
we're already doing this the only thing
is the communities are running it not
the state are there any questions or
anything for representative Roy
okay thank you very much I appreciate it
and also apologize for taking up your
time okay the chair will call again it's
a reformer representative The Honorable
Daniel Itza
thank you Mr chairman uh members of the
committee uh this is in the second uh
representative Terry can you turn in
thank you yeah for the record I'm rep I
am Dan it's uh I reside in Manchester
currently uh I did serve in this house
for 18 years and in fact what the
chairman was referring to was bills that
I brought forward
excuse me
attention
spam
what I have brought forth was much more
extensive than this all this what this
bill does is authorize or require
actually because right now it's
permissive it required would require the
adjutant general to create a Cadre of
officers
I would have when I scoped it out it
would be about 14 commissioned officers
and approximately equal number of
non-commissioned officers to just form
the the core of what could be a state
guard
State guards are something that exist in
23 of the states
some of them are social club some of
them are very effective organizations
one of the reasons one of the advantages
of the state guard is because they are
local they're Town based they deploy out
of their town
their response time is much faster than
the National Guard
National Guard has a requirement of
responding in 72 hours National Guards
typically respond in less than 12 hours
Texas uses them to be the first men on
the scene
so they they deploy they see the
situation they report back to the
National Guard do you need to come if
you do come what do you need to bring
kind of thing
um and I've had extensive conversations
with them with this Texas State guard
State guards New England New York
Massachusetts and Vermont
uh New York and and Massachusetts are
long-standing organizations Vermont
state guard was created after 2001 in
response to it
uh the New York State guard in 911 they
were the first people on site
before the National Guard just as you
would expect
throughout the uh
event they handled all of the traffic
control
around
the the site that meant the National
Guard didn't have to do it they did all
of their work of cleanup
uh things out of the wreckage and the
police were allowed to do their normal
policing functions outside of the site
that so that there was no additional
burden put on the city police due to you
know the the after effects of 9 11. so
there is there is a slot for it
um
it does need to be thought out
extensively
when I put the bills in one of the
things I did was make them much more
volunteer in nature
right now there would be a substance if
you just
implemented the state guard as it exists
in statute today there would be a
substantial financial burden upon the
state
if you make it truly volunteer
you transfer that most of that cost onto
the members
which if they're inclined to volunteer
for it then they'd volunteer for the
expense
I'd be happy to take any questions
thank you
Dan it's anyone have any questions
no questions uh thank you very much
we miss you up here there representative
honorable thank you
um
Terry War you got right okay
uh asked Kevin Grady who opposes the
bill
from the svac
welcome again thank you Mr chairman
ladies and gentlemen the committee once
again for the record my name is Kevin
Grady I'm a 25-year Air Force veteran uh
a 23-year resident of the town of
Hooksett here representing the state
veterans advisory committee
um I'm I'm I can't tell you how happy I
am to have representative Roy sit in
this chair and say that he really thinks
that this bill is not quite ready for
prime time because uh representative Roy
does a lot of good work for us there's
there's four other bills that he's
sponsoring for us that we
enthusiastically support so we hate to
be the people that have to come in and
say we don't think this is ready to go
so we're very very pleased that I was
very pleased to hear him say that it
lets me off the hook a little bit our
problem with this mostly is that there
you know there's just the administrative
burden and the and the money involved
just isn't there right now and there are
Community emergency response teams that
are doing the kinds of things that you
might think you know a natural disaster
where we've got roads that are washed
out or whatever their their local
community groups that are already doing
that and I think there is some value in
trying to pursue this and maybe have a
larger umbrella over all of these
Community emergency response groups in
the various towns that would link it
back to the state and at some point in
time we would need to try and maybe put
some money against this thing so that we
could do some training for example just
a thought I had off the top of my head
every single National Guards person
that's that's trained to drive one of
our vehicles has a license to drive that
specific vehicle and has done that
before
somebody with a CDL license might not
necessarily be able to drive some of the
equipment that the guard has without
some training so we we're going to need
to train those Folks at some point if
we're going to do this and this is it's
an interesting job idea and we we
actually look forward to working with
representative Roy and and trying to
craft something that we think perhaps
better meets uh our needs on this that's
really all I wanted to say sir thank you
any questions for
no question
yes go ahead
the Rotary Club in Londonderry
that's where the money's come from
mm-hmm
I think that
the small organizations like that
well-trained right
I agree with you I was actually one of
the original members on that on the team
the alert and the Chamber uh they they
your group the rotary spent money on the
training with EMTs on carrying those
um
you know medical training carrying
people out of the woods properly
you could have but you but I would have
ignored you
but anyways uh thank you very much
a representative was one of them that
were running the checks I didn't see him
in the woods
all right the chair recognized Warren
Perry once again
welcome again uh
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee again for the record Warren
Perry Deputy adjun General New
Hampshire's Department of military
Affairs and veteran services the
department opposes the bill it creates
uh and and we we
second representative Roy's uh you know
desire to withdraw the bill I provided
written testimony that kind of lays out
our position I'll be happy to address
any part of that testimony but in the
interest of time and your your attention
I think that's the right path to go on
oh second
over here
thank you
.
where am I
1362 and I'm opening up the exec session
on 1362. shall we try to move up Move
Along fast
temporary setback because the chair is
never wrong
right
it's a temporary setback waiting for a
solution
with the help of Christina
okay we ready
are we ready on this
so the uh
so Mr chair the motion is to itl made by
yourself yes and seconded by
Brody awesome thank you bro okay and
seconded by representative deschase
thank you
okay I'll speak real quick we've seen
this many many times this bill here and
although good intentions it means well
but I think local control in many
communities are doing this and it's
making a big difference in the state of
New Hampshire which is helping out
during disasters flooding uh lost kids
in the woods and things like that so I
respect representative Roy uh made it
easy on me and said I TL it so uh any uh
anyone else want to add anything to it
okay uh thank you I'm gonna ask the
clerk to go to a roll call vote
yes to itl
sorry uh representative Logan yes
representative Rollins yes
representative delanis yes uh
representative Foster yes
representative Deshay aye
aye I represented massimilla yeah
representative Piedra yes representative
Perez
a representative
just let me make a note here uh Wilhelm
yes
a representative espica yes
representative
yes representative yes
yes
yes and representative yes
no names
without any objections or going to
consent calendar
okay consent
I will write the blurb on that once
again as I've done over the years
okay
50 you know I'm going to close the
exact session on HB 1362 and I'm going
to open up the exact session on
HB 1106
and give us a second to catch up here
1962 was 15 nothing consent
okay
and I'm gonna represent Massimo did I
hear you say you had a um
a um emotion yes thank you Mr chair
um I motion that we do ought to pass on
1106. okay and I'll second that for you
how's that okay all right uh before we
go into any motion on off the pass and
have you discuss it uh you all have
received the amendment
um is there any questions or concerns on
the amendment for the bill
on the uh request from the National
Guard uh yes
um thank you Mr chair no I think it's uh
I think it's a good amendment I think
you know it covers everything
um I think switching it from a committee
to a commission is a great idea I think
uh keeping the keeping the the changes
in line changing the title I think this
covers everything like that I'd like to
see
so okay thank you is there anyone else
on the amendment
pass on the amendment
I don't see anyone else that wants to
speak okay uh I'm going to ask the clerk
to make a
a roll call vote I better yet oh better
yet uh tell you what yeah watch watch
the magic okay show a hands on who
supports on the uh Amendment ought to
pass
okay very simple 16.
oh okay that's right it's been it's been
a while it's been a while okay okay
disregard what I just said uh we have it
remember what I said the chairman is
never wrong it's just a temporary
setback okay so we're we're okay uh we
have a motion on the floor not to pass
um
by uh representative Massimo second by
me are there any uh discussion on the
author pass
CNS none go to a roll call okay
see we've been we haven't done this in
over a year all right you get out of
practice okay excuse me 1106 motion OTP
uh representative Moffett
president representative Moffett votes I
on the
uh on passing the amendment no no Ronnie
got to pass on the bill
as you were okay
question
not to pass as amended no this is just
sought to pass okay for some reason I
thought we did amendments before but I
just forgot okay
go ahead um
yeah no do you know um uh Madam clerk
could you repeat the uh the the measure
that we're voting on we're voting voting
all
1106 motion OTP
uh uh uh Vice chair votes I
Wonder yes yes representative Rollins
yeah yeah representative delanis yes
representative Foster yes representative
deschet yes
representative massamila yes
representative Piedra
representative Perez yes
representative Wilhelm yes
representative yeah
yes
representative tall
representative labranche yes
yes
and representative yes
okay for some reason this it would sound
right because we're going to do three
votes on this one bill but but that's
fine wait uh okay so that's 16 not
nothing on the ought to pass
amilo yeah
okay
the uh the next one which we already
made on the ought to pass on Amendment
uh
2022-01058 anyone here does not have the
amendment
we can't go out to pass Amendment until
we pass the amendment right we have to
Do adoption Amendment yeah and okay
well she's writing down the amendment is
there any questions or concerns on the
amendment
I know I know you can and no
okay okay without any objection then I
will go to the vote when the clerk is
ready
OTP on the amendment
um I move the amendment
and then Linda Massimo will move the
otpa
what's that
yeah but we haven't voted on the
amendment yet
what's that
it's okay well okay
so I saw don't I have to report the
amendment's been passed
it's otpa
all right this must be new rules okay
thanks
yeah all right thank you do you need a
motion show give me just to be on a safe
side give me a show of Hands-On
Amendment all in favor okay 16 to
nothing put down on the sheet because we
got to report the amendment 16 to
nothing
okay uh representative Master Miller you
have amendment I mean a motion to make
yes uh yes Mr chairman I'd like to
recommend
um audit paths as amended okay I have a
motion on the floor to pass as Amendment
I'd be more happy the second now with my
friend representative Mass Miller
okay now the next motion is ought to
pass as amended
we did too many um
right right yeah
no this one here by her that's why I
just switch it
okay
um would you like to discuss on your
motion
thank you is there any other discussion
on a ought to pass as amended
everyone good on it as soon as the clerk
is ready I'll ask for a roll call
I
representative Lundgren yes and
representative Rollins yeah and
representative delanis yes and
representative Binford no Foster sorry
yeah
representative deschet yes
representative
massamila yes and representative Pedro
yes and representative Congress yes
yes
and representative yes
that's 16-0
without any uh objection uh on the
consent calendar
okay it's on the consent
so I'll see you and T I will close the
here executive session on 1106. our next
hearing is at 1 45 I will be introducing
the bill representative moff will be
sitting in as the chair
okay
next Friday I might be able to catch a
plane early then instead of wait until
Saturday
I'm actually probably flying out
tomorrow
okay uh yeah we're off until 1 45 for
the next bill
yes um
you got a sheet for uh her for Linda
uh oh yeah yes
got one here somewhere
they used to have these colored and now
yeah they used to be yeah blue and
yellow so they all look alike so it's
kind of
[Music]
kind of snow
okay I um yes I have to write a blurb on
um
yeah on the itl
oh
stand by
that would have been precious
Precious Precious Moments oh my
oh my God
I don't need this right here
is there a reason why we haven't exact
activities they all wanted or something
or we just have a caucus
the very first one good question
because it's actually a split on it
yeah there's a split if it was clearly
consent calendar type thing would be
easy to do this this is some debate
coming up now okay
okay stand by
it being 145 or 13.45 I'd like to call
the next measure to order and that would
be House Bill one three five three uh
the issue of renaming a wing in the New
Hampshire veterans home and I'd like to
recognize the prime sponsor of this
measure representative baldisaro uh
thank you Mr chairman and fellow
committee members uh put a record
representative Al baldussell Rockingham
County District 5 which is Londonderry
um HB 1353 I got a phone call a while
ago from executive Joe Kenny Marine
Corps Colonel uh retired who said to me
that uh Barry uh
pretty much calmly got a bad deal over
in the Senate there they had a bill that
was passed end up being tabled for one
reason another on some stuff that was
brought forward
I talked with somebody and I mentioned
the names but I did talk with a couple
people about some things that they said
Barry did when he was the commandant and
I talked with Barry and of course uh he
swears up and down you know that he'd
bring his employment records and
everything forward and that it never
happened so I wasn't going to get in the
tip of that all I know is you know when
I see a lot of people that are
supporting this I said okay well I'll
bring It Forward let me first of all
give you a little bit history I've been
fortunate enough as being on this
committee for over 15 years I worked
with Barry Conway for many many years I
felt that he was a very professional
individual uh Was A Cut Above and really
kid for the veterans he was a veteran
himself
some of his accomplishments uh was
basically here
um first of all I'll give you he was a
chief executive officer senior
administrator program program director
non-profit Health Care Facility
management Veterans Services facility
development operations funding and
fiscal management strategic planning
marketing this is just some of his
background he was familiar with Grant
and contract development and
Acquisitions legislation development
with state and federal officials he was
in our committee many many times
testifying on legislation
um
very educated individual operated a
budget about 36 million dollars he had
about 200 plus personal staff
you know in a 250 I believe it's about
250 unit beds I maybe off a few but I
think it's 250 if I remember right
um and he did a good job I mean you know
the guy was educated
um master's degree in public
administration
as a chairman here before in the vice
chair and on this committee never ever
did I ever get a complaint in here on
Barry Conway that's why I'm kind of
surprised when I hear about the bullying
and some other stuff that you may hear
coming up and I think it's a personal
records issue that uh we have to be
careful on uh because he swears up and
down that that's never happened so I'm
not going to get in for a Tit for Tat on
this here I'm just concerned there
because of my experience Whit Barry has
been A Cut Above in
I I just thought he did a great great
job here I give you an idea
um
on some of his
um you know notable achievements during
his time uh he definitely increased
resident census From Below uh 100 to
almost 200 established an on-site
Pharmacy he initiated electronic health
record system he established two new
positions on the board of managers the
Marine Corps League and the Vietnam
veterans America he received and
developed Capital project grants funded
by 65 percent of federal Veterans
Administration VA grants including the
TA South 50 bed unit
maintenance on the building Emergency
Center and Storehouse would receive any
in shipping terminal a geothermal
project new kitchen and cafeteria solar
panels on much of the building roofing
Life Enhancement dementia unit
a state-of-the-art 100 resident bed
residents for veterans with Alzheimer's
disease
and I believe at least from what I
gather because no complaints ever came
to us
um
you know we boarded you know he worked
with the board of manager governing
executive council state reps and
Senators
um you know on the um in the
Congressional Delegation uh throughout
the years of him being at the nursing
home
uh and this is why I'm kind of surprised
I don't know what the problem was in the
Senate but I see him uh this going
forward in uh with the support you know
uh hopefully with the Senate
um you know on this legislation
and if Barry was here he was in Florida
you know he would be able to sit here
and defend himself
and I'm looking around here I don't know
I think it represents you what is I
think at the time when Barry was around
and uh you know like I said I was kind
of shocked where it didn't you know it
didn't pass that's why I did not mind
picking this up and bringing it forward
now a long time friend of mine who was
the VFW committeeman for many years and
been in this committee many times Assad
major Paul Chevalier he sent me a
message and he said to me Al what do we
need to do to get this moved uh let me
know and I'd be honest with you I
haven't had a chance to write Paul
Chevalier back and ask him to submit a
letter okay I've been busy here all week
on other legislation but um there's also
been other letters that you should have
gotten to your emails you know on his
you know recommending um you know that
we support this here you know and people
that he's worked with you know on these
letters that were submit good
I don't know uh Jackie bonafide
who's a former NH veterans home program
information officer worked for him I
wrote a great letter
um
trying to think here in the other
letters
uh like I said this is a you know to me
is a no-brainer so I'm hoping and I've
seen that we have some kind of people
that were against it and
I'm hoping that here that you know we do
the right thing and pass this and uh
this is long overdue on a man a veteran
who took charge with the veterans
community who in my opinion kept those
veteran numbers up
okay and even though he didn't have
covid you know uh that slowed him down
but he made damn well show we were
bringing veterans in and filling those
beds up at the veterans home so I highly
recommend that we uh support this bill
uh to name you know they have his name
over on the enhancement of the dementia
unit in New Hampshire Veterans Home uh
you know calling it The Barry Conway
unit since he played a very big pot on
getting it in
so with that I'll leave it at that and
uh be open for any questions
are there any questions for the prime
sponsor
seeing none I will say thank you uh
representative
and we'll go to our cards here
representative we'd like a pink card
from you
if we could get one eventually
uh top my list here is uh next up would
be uh Paul Lloyd
to oppose the bill
from a local VFW Commander
good afternoon
my name is Paul Lloyd I'm the chairman
for the board of managers at the
veterans home
chairman of the state veterans advisory
committee
state adjunate for New Hampshire VFW and
currently serving a full year at the
national level at the Inspector General
so
I'm here for the board of managers the
board of managers has voted they do not
support this bill
and the reason being is some of the
things that we found out after Barry
retired now
that being said before we go on he did
great things while he was commandant
um
but after he retired we've learned of
some things that were not
um
we're not good
he was
accused of hostile work environment
I think in 2007 2008
he fired a worker and the labor board
agreed with the worker and put her back
in a position
we also have
unsubstantiated
allegations of sexual harassment
and I say unsubstantiated no one put pen
to paper
but we were told of instance of sexual
harassment
um
and that's why the board of managers do
not support this
thank you
thank you for your testimony would you
take any questions sure yes sir are
there any questions for
Mr Lloyd
see uh as you were uh representative
delamis
allegations were up to unsubishi
substantiated and no one put pen to
paper why even bring that up it's as far
as it sounds as though it's hearsay did
you speak directly with the woman who
claims that she was molested
I did
um
but she's no longer with us that's why
there was no pen to paper
she passed a few years ago
other questions
seeing none thank you Mr Lloyd thank you
uh
representative balls here I I think is a
response to the if you could go to a
microphone if you would mind so that you
could respond
yeah I I get the utmost respect my
friend Paul Lloyd but making the
accusations like this here unstentuated
uh on and this is played on YouTube
we're setting ourselves up for a uh a
suit okay so I want to be careful here
that the committee the Veterans Affairs
committee has nothing to do with that
testimony and it's not on our behalf
that it came forward just in case
something comes out of this
so we brought it up on the record there
to make sure that the state of New
Hampshire is protected thank you
thank you for the response
all right next up on our list is uh
Warren Perry again
who uh also signed in an opposition
so for the record on Warren Perry
representing myself not the department
of military Affairs and veteran services
as in other testimony today I would only
say that my experience with
memorializing buildings and wings and
bridges generally is done posthumously
and to my knowledge Mr Conway is still
alive
so I just think it's odd and my
opposition is not necessarily based on
any testimony you heard here but
generally we wait to memorialize things
until they're memorialized uh and uh
that's just my feeling based on
you know how we name things
so subject to your questions that
concludes my statement
are there any questions
yeah I have a question uh chair
organized representative wilkowitz thank
you
um
thanks for the opportunity to ask you a
question
um would would delaying this give us
some time to also to learn more about
this I feel like I'm blindsided here by
some by opposition of people who I
respect a lot
is there what do you think of a delay or
I I
in general thank you for thank you for
the question representative in general I
I always ask this question when people
bring to me problems is this a decision
that I have to make right now
and I and if the answer is no then I go
find out more information and that's
generally the litmus test that I use
with regard to any information you may
uncover with regard to the
appropriateness of this memorialization
of this Wing I mean that's that's really
uh the will of the committee but I try
never to rush to failure as a just as a
personal
uh as a personal matter and if I don't
have to make a decision right now I
generally delay it till I have enough
information that leads me to the proper
decision
I I don't I'm not trying to dodge your
question but it's really up to you
for uh yes representative
representative Lawton here my uh
question is you had stated
um that we normally wait until someone
is you know either passed on or whatnot
would this be something you would
support for this individual you know
after said time for them so again I I uh
I'm not gonna thank you for the question
representative I'm not going to dodge
your question but I'm probably not going
to answer it either I mean again I have
no direct knowledge of Mr Conway's
character in either in his
accomplishments or anything that may
deter from his accomplishments I don't
have any reason with that you know the
sole reason for my testimony today is
that generally my ex my experience has
been we wait until the person is passed
and we make these memorializations
posthumously generally
I don't know of very many times in the
military where we name something after
somebody who's alive
uh it would have to be a pretty special
thing
even Medal of Honor recipients they kind
of wait
uh further questions did I see here
representative Perez
yes thank you for the opportunity may I
ask you if um
do you believe that that we has to wait
until the person pass away until to mem
to give something to memorize the person
uh I I don't I don't think I was saying
my beliefs just my experiences right so
my my beliefs are that uh that we my
beliefs are my beliefs right so and I
and I believe that it's appropriate to
wait till it's till they've passed away
to memorialize them generally the
memorialization is in remembrance of
that person and a tribute to them for
their families most of the time are
there instances where people have been
memorialized before their death I'm sure
there are uh I I just don't think it's
appropriate and I've said I guess that's
again I came here expressing my opinion
and and and my experiences so that's my
my belief
I don't think it's bad that we do it
before they die but I just don't think
it's normal and I would I think it's
more appropriate after
further questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
sir
the final card I have here is for
um Margaret Libre
who also poses a bill and um indicated
that she would submit a written
testimony as well
this is Ms lebreck thank you for being
here
could you turn the microphone on please
employee of Mr Conway's so again I have
a memorandum from me
um in my prior conversations with chair
baldosaro you know he said that the uh
the one problem that he heard about was
only one employee and unfortunately I'm
here to tell you a lot of employees
don't come forward when they have issues
with bullying and we all know that and
especially somebody who is in high
standing right they are the department
head they are the person that talks to
Concord and so many long-term state
employees don't come forward they put
down their head they do their job every
day and they go forward and hope to
retire and not be uh targeted
so again I have written here an instance
that refers to what Mr Lloyd was
speaking of in the employee who wasn't
terminated and then actually won the
suit and was resigned
um
and then later wrote in in your packet
and expose that was put on the internet
so it is public knowledge of a horrible
boss and and if you go to that page two
two years into her job as the public
affairs director of the New Hampshire
Veterans Home you know Lisa Marie began
to feel that her boss had it out for her
and then she explains what happened
there
and again with my conversations with um
chair bald sorrow
you know he said you know there was only
one person and so I read this again and
I said to myself
you know shame on me because I was a
director at the New Hampshire veterans
home and there were times when I was
directed to remove people from a
leadership role or a staff meeting and
and to no longer invite them to that
staff meeting and
again he was my boss so I did as I was
told but maybe in hindsight I I should
have looked further into it so um I
guess I I feel that I own some of that
as well that there were other employees
who were Uninvited to staff meetings and
therefore didn't know of the going-ons
at a higher level than
um and maybe they should have or I
believe that they were at that meeting
for a reason and should have continued
I go on to talk about
um when Mr Conway let us know that he
was retiring and he brought it up to
myself and so I pursued and and got my
nursing home administrator's license I
went through the process as all state
employees right
um we are compensated with salary and
benefits and good retirement so I want
to be a long-term state employee
um my application went through human
resources and I was approved to have an
interview
um the day before I was to have that
interview he approached me and told me
that he was going to pull my application
and he was going to tell the
interviewees that I had pulled my
application and so I will tell you I
told him quite vehemently that I didn't
agree with that I was upset but again
I'm a long-term state employee who
doesn't want to lose my job
so I went to my office and did my job
and when approached as you can see by
both General protzman and Director of
Veterans Services Mary Morin that they
were sad that I had pulled my
application so that I knew that indeed
Mr Conway had not told the truth to
those interviewees and that bothered me
but as things would turn out
the person that he had selected to be
the next commandant backed out at the
11th hour and so he told me I was his
plan B
and as you can imagine that didn't go
over very well but a good I'm a good
state employee and I love my veterans
and they'll do everything I can to
protect the veterans and the veterans
home so I went forward and spoke to the
board of managers at that time and they
actually
um put me forward to the governor to be
the actual commandant and today nine
years later I am deed am the commandant
looking to retire with a state wonderful
State Pension again
um
um again I've got other information here
just for your you know I ask you to
review it from a different point of view
I will tell you that bullies don't bully
people in power
right bullies bully people that they
think are not in power or have lost the
ability to fight back
and um
that's how I feel in regards and
unfortunately I worked for Mr Conway for
eight years seven years excuse me and it
bothered me that he did that to me but
again why rock the boat when you could
lose your job and you could lose the
wages that you uh take care of your
family with so
any questions
thank you for your testimony and thank
you for offering to take questions are
there any questions
uh representative Massimo
thank you
thank you Miss uh representative often
and thank you for taking my questions
were there any other people who came to
you
during your tenure under Mr Conway that
had experienced similar problems
again
um there were I two reports that
directly reported to me who were removed
from higher level staff meetings and
uninvited to attend
um but I must tell you they were
long-term employees so they just put
their heads down and did their job right
and because they knew that I was between
I was now between them and him and they
felt that I would protect them and they
would continue on with their job and
both of them have since retired and I
don't mention their name because I don't
feel it's my I shouldn't put their names
out there and if I identify their
position which is a leadership position
they should have been on that leadership
but again shame on me for not
fighting back at that time
yes thank you Mr chair
um were there problems similar to yours
yes okay thank you
uh representative
it's more so rather than a a question
for you I just want to thank you for
coming and speaking to us today thank
you
I want to thank
you do I have permission to speak uh
representative thank you
just want to thank you as well
as well sorry that that happened to you
and your colleagues but your courage
inspires others to speak out and so I
admire you and thank you so much for
coming and sharing today it makes a
difference again I leave these documents
with you so you can review them and take
them into consideration
again the New Hampshire Veterans Home
does everything we can to not only care
for our resident veterans but our staff
and my last statement is with dignity
honor and respect and I do not believe
that Mr Conway dealt that way with
everybody
is there anything else for the speaker
saying I'm uh thank you so much for uh
for your testimony thank
you thank you see if there's anyone else
who is here who would want to speak to
this bill
in saying none I will declare this
session the sharing on this bill to be
over
245.
all right it's um
I'd I'd like to ask a question to
Margaret
Madame commandant
any of this stuff that you brought up is
it documented in records
all the information that I provided here
had gone before the board of managers an
RSA right to know request was made by Mr
Conway that made it public documents
okay I'm just wondering why um
15 years on this board never ever once
everyone every time I've been over there
people no they had opportunities to come
up and talk to us they knew I was the
chairman or vice chair or another nobody
ever and I knew quite a bit at the time
they worked over there because I was
there more with Barry under his watch
than your watch and uh I'm just
wondering why nobody ever came forward
and I I think it's uh it's a shame that
now all of a sudden because he's gone
that this stuff comes up and he denies
it a hundred percent on on the bullying
and I know Mr chairman
who's speaking it's my understanding
that if you testified you cannot ask
Witnesses questions I can't hear it's my
understanding of the house rules that if
you testified in support of a bill you
cannot ask questions of a witness
it is huh why don't you check the
Chairman's handbook
rather than a representative because you
have to come to me and then I'm the one
who you know can ask a question to
somebody that this is off the Record the
right the committee it's already closed
I'm just trying to figure out something
here because this is on YouTube and I
just want to make sure that this stuff
is in the record because if this comes
forward lawyers and other stuff on
personal stuff that's been brought up
here that you prepared and you have
documentation absolutely sir okay this
has all been made public by Mr Conway
doing an RSA 91a and the New Hampshire
Veterans Home opened up their
documentation for the board of managers
meetings and so it has been posted on
our website since the meeting occurred
and the Horrible Bosses has been out on
the internet and it can be Googled since
2000 and
is it a one person due to a uh and I'm
just trying to get more on this here
before we expect something like that
because everyone I mean it's a shame
only the managers that are there today
and yourself but everyone else that I
know and talk to speak very highly of
the guy and I mean it's like the general
I mean how many times the general leaves
and then everyone found fault with the
general you know after the general
already moved on although but the CEO so
I'm just wondering is this what's going
on with uh you know Barry Conway
so again you can read my memo exactly my
interaction with Mr Conway and you can
read what Lisa Marie mulkarn spoke about
in her interaction and
as I um
I'm not going to argue with you no I'm
not looking out I just want to find out
I'm telling you the God's honest truth
of what happened and what occurred and
um
I guess you could say it's a he said she
said yeah I'm just I'm just kind of
surprised that's why for many years none
of this ever came to us or
I know when we did an audit a few years
ago we found so many problems there
you know they're on to the audit but
that he was already long gone you know
what I mean but uh okay thank you
in the hallway
yeah am I right is that clock wrong or
yeah
246. okay we all set
I'm going to open up the hearing on uh
1505.
representative Roy
um I just actually answered his texts
wait a minute I didn't realize I'm
on this bill
wow
okay
tell you what I'm gonna pass this over
to my uh chairman since Roy is not here
and I'll introduce the bill
at this time we're going to reconvene
this hearing
on HB 1505
establishing concurrent jurisdiction
juvenile juvenile matters with the U.S
Department of Defense for coordination
with the military family advocacy
program and uh the prime sponsor
representative Roy is not present
fortunately the co-sponsor
representative Bell desero is here
and uh representative thank you for
being here at this time
oh thank you uh Mr chairman uh for the
record representative Al bald and sour
Rockingham County uh what district five
which is Londonderry
okay this bill was recommended by the
Department of Defense here
um and in the beginning I didn't have a
clue about it until uh the gentleman who
was supposed to be here today can't make
it which is represent I mean Christopher
Arnold he's the Northeast region liaison
on behalf of the Department of Defense
I am through over the years of sponsored
legislation that the Department of
Defense comes up with a list of like the
10 most important pieces of legislation
that they try to set up and be put in to
help veterans that move into different
states throughout the country so this is
basically one of those bills
um it's an act established in concurrent
jurisdiction in juvenile matters with
the U.S Department of Defense for
coordination with the military family
advocacy program
we have in place already a school
compact uh we have other stuff in place
there for you know which we do in the
school systems to help when when
veterans move into the area
this I think is an another step in the
right area uh on helping and dealing
with troubles I believe uh Utes and all
that and then dealing with uh
information systems working hand in hand
with the military family advocacy groups
on military bases and I'm going to have
there's going to be some people behind
me uh there's also an amendment being
drafted as we speak
for the dcyf and he'll come up and
explain that there on a couple of
Corrections that we're going to make on
this bill here uh it's basically it's a
win-win for the state I I wish uh
Christopher was here to explain it more
in detail
I'm hoping you all got a copy of his
from the Secretary of State
did y'all get a copy of the letter and
it goes into detail and on helping with
the veterans uh
you know and their children in the
system yeah you know and we're moving
basically barriers uh you know
um retro session in concurrent
jurisdiction on who's involved when it
comes to military you know children so
it's probably better that I let some of
the people behind me step up to the
plate and give a little bit more insight
because this is pretty much a win-win
for the veteran community and I oh
highly hope that we supported 150
percent
thank you
thank you for that introduction
and it sounds like the representative is
waived questions in lieu of subsequent
testimony by
those who have signed up to testify and
at the top of our list here I see uh is
Kevin Gandy who is signed in to support
the bill
thank you Mr chairman once again for the
record my name is Kevin Grady uh 25-year
Air Force veteran 23-year resident of
the town of Hooksett here representing
today the state veterans advisory
committee
um when we first looked at this bill I
have to be honest with you I had to read
it two or three times to try and figure
out what we were we're doing with it
because I'm not a lawyer and I don't
play one on TV but I will tell you that
that what we're trying to do in a lot of
cases here we've already we've already
established a basis for a lot of that in
our state and our committee felt
strongly that the more the more that
that when that when a federal program
which is required to come down and deal
with Family Matters from the from the
federal level down to the state level
when those folks come down and and they
they sort of have a list of of things
that they're trying to accomplish you
can bet that somewhere back in
Washington DC there is a chart on a wall
and it's got like green lights and red
lights and Amber lights and all that in
terms of how well all of this stuff is
being received by the various states
that are going down there and
our our people were kind of uh
certain that we're doing a lot of these
things we have advocacy for a lot of
these things and all we need to do now
is just kind of go down this road with
this kind of legislation and then if
there's some follow-on things that we
need to tweak to get it done then all of
a sudden we're on the green on all of
these programs and it's our our thought
that when you when the state and the
federal government is involved in
something together the more that those
rules and and plans can be the same as
you work your way all the way down to
the local level probably the better off
we all are there are folks behind me and
of course Mr Arnold's letter explains
kind of a lot of what they're trying to
accomplish better than I possibly could
so I think I'm going to let the other
experts testify to this but we do
support this legislation from the state
veterans advisory committee
thank you Mr Grady do you are you
available for questions at this time if
somebody has some I may not be able to
answer it but I will be happy to try
and it sounds like we have some more
expert testimony coming uh thank you Mr
Gray I think I pronounced it Gandhi the
first time okay without my glasses on
right
all right next up
uh is Warren Perry I think I pronounced
that one right uh Who's Back Again
speaking
uh in support of the bill
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee once again for the record
Warren Perry Deputy Edge and General New
Hampshire's Department of military
Affairs and veteran services I have Miss
cook with me uh Amy Cook who is the
administrator of the division of
community-based military programs the
department supports this bill we work
very closely with Mr Arnold and his
office
at the Department of Defense they are
the proponency for military families
Nationwide and Mr Arnold specifically
deals with region one which is
essentially the Northeast
he has provided some very detailed
written testimony and what this bill
does essentially is
codifies into statute the procedures
that are already that already exist and
the agreements that already exist
between the federal government uh
particularly the federal government and
the state of New Hampshire so we're
already doing the things that the law is
asking us to do and now we're gonna
we're gonna memorialize that in statute
so again you know I'm not I'm not an
expert in in you know domestic abuse or
the things that the the law gets after
addressing what we find is the more
cooperatively we work with the you know
with Mr Arnold in his office the more
support we get from them as well so we
not only do we take care of the families
associated with the circumstances that
the the law addresses but we also
continue to gain support and uh and a
good partnership with uh with the
Department of Defense so subject to any
of your questions that concludes my
statement
thank you
uh I have a question
um
so is they look at the the new language
correct me if I'm wrong but basically it
is saying that the that the feds get
first dibs on uh dealing with a
a alleged crime
um before the state does is that kind of
what's the language says if in fact the
crime occurs on a federal reservation
right so and that that's generally the
way it is so if we were at Fort Knox or
Fort Drum New York and the crime occurs
on the federal installation you know the
confines of that installation
jurisdiction generally defaults to the
federal government because it happened
in those lands what this law does is
says the state can handle this and now
we can bring to bear the resources in
both the federal system and the state
system to solve the problem and that's
really the the solution that's trying to
be applied here and again there isn't
there is an agreement between uh between
the state of New Hampshire and the
federal government that talks about
these things and really what we want to
do is just kind of codify that in
statute
it says that uh
the state shall assume jurisdiction only
if waived by the federal court or U.S
attorney I'm just curious uh does that
happen do you know this is it did the
feds ever waive power absolutely
absolutely just just like any courts
they fight over who has to do it not who
wants to do it okay
all right so I think it's more I think
it's it's more common than you would
think I mean the federal court system
doesn't necessarily have the resources
to deal with domestic abuse I mean
they're dealing with federal crimes and
federal issues certainly
so the state is more suited more
resource in let's be fair right
everybody has limited resources in these
times right and in all times so the
courts are overburdened but the federal
government doesn't have really a system
to deal with domestic abuse in the same
scope that the state does so you're
concern about the federal government
ceding their Authority in this
particular case I think they would say
they're more apt to seated because it's
better suited for the state to handle
these issues very if that makes any
sense that's very interesting other
questions for uh yes representative yeah
thank you for letting me ask a question
thank you
um so I'm just trying to understand I'm
a clinical psychologist in Keene and if
there can't psychoanalyze me
representative while I'm here a little
bit just a little bit
um so when there's an abuse accusation
for example child abuse there's this 800
line that goes right to the state to the
dcyf yes and we call that and that
starts this whole investigation process
would this bill the art first of all are
there Federal investigators as well are
there people who just do it for the feds
I think I I think would be more precise
to say there are people who work for the
federal government who do that kind of
work and it's not like the FBI is out to
do it so I'd make a distinction between
a federal investigator and somebody who
is in the employment of the federal
government to do that right so I would I
make that distinction and I'm probably
splitting hairs a little bit okay so how
does it roll so in those cases I mean
military installations have
Investigative Services just like
everywhere else so at Fort Knox there's
a criminal investigation division they
have people who who investigate and
prosecute crimes in a system just like
they would in any district court in New
Hampshire they do that is there a
federal number like the suicide hotline
that that deals with domestic abuse the
answer to that question is I just don't
know but if there's an allegation of
domestic violence or abuse the military
particularly and this is where we're
dealing has systems to deal with and
Report those things and the question
really just becomes of uh of where
jurisdiction lies and it's probably a
very similar system to sexual assault
right so if a sexual assault occurs on a
military installation and there's been a
lot of news about that frankly in the
military and is the is the military
appropriately investigating those things
but uh you know there's a jurisdictional
piece that goes and at some point the
federal investigator whoever it is at
that local installation may decide that
this is a matter for the Civil courts
just depending on what goes on really
what's at issue here is the federal
confines of peas or new federal property
that's in New Hampshire that's
associated with the military and there's
not a lot of it pees Air Force Base or
peace Air National Guard base is really
the place that it would most likely
happen but there are no really family
members that work there or reside there
so the issue in New Hampshire is
relatively small
uh but and and that's another reason to
pass the law because it's it's more
appropriate for the Civil Authorities to
manage it back to your question and I've
talked a long way I'm not aware of any
single number that's called to to deal
with a hotline for domestic abuse that's
a federal line I am I am aware that the
military in New Hampshire the National
Guard the reserves The Navy Reserves the
Army Reserves uh the full-time
recruiters have systems in their chains
of command for reporting and
investigating issues of domestic abuse
or violence right so under this bill I'm
just trying to understand if there is a
call to the state 800 number of say
child abuse at a federal
facility right yes like peas or
something
would that then trigger the D the state
dcyf to alert the yes the feds and then
and and then the fed the military then
would lead would take the lead in
deciding how that investigation would
proceed would it be done by military
investigators or dcyf investigators I
think no I think that the first part of
your statement is absolutely correct
dcyf or the state whoever receives the
call from the state would have an
obligation to notify the federal the the
the appropriate Federal investigative
agency at that point a decision would be
made where it's most appropriate to
handle the investigative process okay I
and as I answered to the chair I believe
that the federal government in this
particular instance would believe that
it's more appropriate to do that
investigation it's in the state system
not the federal system well I would hope
so I guess my concern just trying to
understand how the law would work is
that somehow that the uh maybe the fed
the military investigators would would
take it on when in fact they didn't have
the capacity that the dcyf had but I
think that's a possibility but more than
really really really really remote now
it might be it might be a different
issue at Fort Hood Texas where there are
40 000 soldiers on a military
installation but in New Hampshire
total actively serving population is
less than six thousand and that's from
all four five components including space
force and the Coast Guard and the guard
and Reserve so I it's and it's and
there's no structure there's no military
structure in New Hampshire for that to
be the appropriate response
okay so the actual office that deals
with this for New Hampshire is in is in
Massachusetts
so that that that military Hub is in
Massachusetts and my understanding is I
haven't seen it I've asked Mr Arnold to
provide it that there is a memorandum of
understanding between that office and
Health and Human Services
another another follow-up
uh no I I think I'm set yeah so and I I
guess I would close my statement by
saying and they are and they are
coordinating with each other already
okay
other questions
uh representative Lawton
um would this mean like like local
police would uh handle this like
Portsmouth Police or State Police or
like you said this would be handled by
local authorities which local Authority
so I think I think the initial response
may be made by local police departments
but dcyf would have the responsibility
to conduct whatever investigation that
goes on that's my understanding again I
I'm not here to speak for the Department
of Health and Human Services or dcyf so
I have to be careful about my response
but I think the initial response may be
made by local law enforcement but it
would be referred to the appropriate
investigative agency after that
other follow-ups
uh you're you're good representative one
uh other questions
seeing none uh speaking of uh dcyf I
have a pink card here from Joe ripson uh
if I said that correctly the director
and he is here yes
he's going to clean it up
good afternoon everybody Joe ripsom
director dcyf thank you for having me
today the department is in support of
this bill with a couple minor amendments
that I'll speak about in a minute before
that I'll speak to some of the
conversation that was just happening
before I came here to New Hampshire I
was in New Jersey for about 10 years
I've been here for about four doing this
work
um we had a we have a couple military
bases in New Jersey where we had you
know active military living on base in
those instances
um what typically would happen was they
would call us to our child protection
system to do the investigation if there
was an allegation of abuse or neglect
New Hampshire we don't have a lot of
folks living on on base I don't know if
we have any but I've never experienced
in New Hampshire having a call to invest
to investigate somebody living on base
if you have active military living off
of Base the state is always the person
to do the investigation and the thing
that we like about this piece of
legislation is that it opens up the
ability for us to legally share
information with the family advocacy
program when we get a call about a
military family who's actively and who's
active in the military and it's helpful
because the family advocacy program has
a lot of resources to help support
families identify what the issues are
try to help solve the problems and if
there's really a big concern about
what's happening in that house be able
to use you know the military
um you know authority to help take care
of some of the some of the issues that
might be happening within that home so
we're in support of the bill because we
think it's going to be helpful for us to
be able to make sure that whenever we
get a call involving a family that's
active military the family advocacy
program will be able to also help out in
addition to what the state brings but we
would maintain the investigatory
responsibility in the investigatory
Authority it would really be about
accessing the military services to help
the family in that instance
the couple minor amendments that we're
asking for are just to clarify the point
at which we'd be able to share
information with the military as this is
drafted I think it was intended to do to
make to change the way that I'm
recommending that it be changed as it
was drafted though we would not be
allowed to contact the military until
after we completed an investigation and
until after we made a finding of abuse
or neglect we want to tweak the language
a little bit just to make clear that we
can make that contact with the military
at the start of an investigation so that
they can come in and help out
immediately and not wait for a full
process to to go through and go to court
and everything else before we get to
tell them about it so the two minor
changes are just changing the
codification one section up sooner
because it's currently codified in a
part of the statute that only talks
about once a once an investigation is
complete the other change we would like
to make is just in Section 3 a currently
reads if a report is accepted as a
founded allegation which to us means
we've made a we've investigated and made
a finding change that to say if a report
is screened in for investigation which
means that we could have contact at the
moment we started investigation still
waiting instead of waiting for it to
finish and with that I'm happy to take
any questions
are there any questions
so I'm looking at the uh the bill that I
have
and
um is
Mr chair Mr original chair is there an
amendment
um
okay so all right that's why
all right thank you Miss Mr former Mr
original chair
uh that is my question okay so this is
uh that was a good question as to this
is what I'm looking at is not the final
recommended amended version correct okay
other questions uh representative
locowitz thank you Mr chair
um Mr ripson uh just thank you one other
question so it's the purpose of of
making that change so that you could
contact the military at an earlier point
is the is the purpose to help gather and
do assessment or for intervention is it
to get Services going in place or is it
to collect more information it's really
it the most typical usage and we did
this in New Jersey as well is to help
get extra services in place for the
family that's typically what the family
advocacy program is doing I've not seen
an incident of this in in New Hampshire
I had seen one in New Jersey where there
was some really extreme physical abuse
happening in a military household and
the military was able to intervene
through their you know legal processes
to to address those issues as well as
the state I've not seen that here
fortunately
other questions
seeing none I would thank you very much
for you being here
and I seen a more pink cards and I see
no one else in the room so given that we
will declare this hearing uh at this
time closed
thank you okay the next um
if I may uh
yeah if I may um the next hearing's at 3
45 I some of these bills uh you know I
the way I schedule them here looking at
thinking that like they were
um the dod guy was going to be here
today and it would be a little bit
longer so I figured he's out and that
way enough time to
um maybe some I can slide in and exec
bill so it's less on the end of the week
next week so if once we get the
amendment and I'll talk with your
ranking member if you're all on board
with this bill then you know we'll put
this to bed also you know I mean and
then uh you know so that will keep an
eye on the amendment when it comes
forward okay so uh
like I said the next bill is at uh two
four three forty five is there anything
that we need to add uh on anybody
no yeah no we'll have time we'll move it
uh
yelling for people if it comes yeah
we'll take it it should probably be
about an hour anyways half hour yeah
okay so uh have a cup of coffee uh I
heard representative Mass Miller's
buy-in so you enjoy yikes that's what I
heard
this is true
foreign
uh
yeah
subscribers
well this is my first pandemics okay
foreign
certain things
thank you
foreign
three teaspoons up
okay
appreciate it yeah
foreign
request
s
usually
Are You Naughty yeah I'm stuck in the
corner now
like it makes you appreciate them a lot
more
especially if you don't have one of
those machines that will like
throw it out
oh
that's why we run so yeah
right
foreign
thank you
generation
baby I'm saying
foreign
here
are exceptions before
because it's basically live and five
seconds later
good thanks
foreign
something
yeah so
some of them
and the other question is um
kind of trying to understand why you
would have the universities
they were they were voting
vote I didn't know
anything that I understand
so so I understand that and I
recommend you got his testimony
I understand that but I'm just
understanding how it would fit
oh
yeah
that's great he's a great state senator
he's um
tell you
okay everyone should have got that
Amendment
um that came in so once we get done with
this we'll probably go ahead and exec
that
very desirable when I when I started
college
not another chance
okay can we take your seats please
you're all set
I want to open up the hearing on House
Bill 1441 and establishing a commission
organized organized The Observer
observations of the 250th anniversary of
the Declaration of Independence and I
want to welcome representative Timothy
horrigon to the committee
he even gave us written testimony good
job Timothy
welcome
it's good to be here um
certainly Aldo certainly as the chairman
knows very well I'm representative
Timothy Horrigan from the towns of uh
from Stratford County six which is the
towns of Durham and Madbury and that's
actually where uh
two of my three
co-sponsors are are from two and one of
whom was representative wall is on this
committee and
apparently uh maybe uh she's considering
a she may be drafting an amendment but
that won't be ready uh ready for a while
so historical issues behind this are are
very complicated uh but its aim is
basically pretty simple to start
planning for the Hampshire's observance
of the 250th anniversary of the
Declaration of Independence and
probably noticed around if you read the
bill you know OLS put this rather
lengthy latinate word sester Centennial
the bill which apparently basically
means one plus one and a half hundred
years
and the federal American 250 commission
is using another long word I think
that's even longer but I've encountered
the letters semi quintessenial which
means half of 500 years so um
one of my constituents Senator Gene
Shaheen is a member of the United States
sesame
Quinn Centennial commission I think
that's the last time well I guess maybe
I'll say that word one more time if I
read but I don't want to say that word
anymore so I'm usually using the 250th
anniversary and the
there's uh there already has been a
federal quote America 250 commission
which Senator Shaheen sits on and that's
been going since 2016. so it's coming up
in four years in the state of New
Hampshire
my opinion needs to do something to Mark
the 250th anniversary of July for 1776
when the 13 colonies became the United
States of America
I'm like I don't know if my nation is
more divided than it ever has been I
mean we did have a it's probably not as
bad as the Western the Civil War but
it's the most divided it's been in my
lifetime and
last years have been tough due to the
pandemic and the political you know just
the general political unrest and chaos
but we are still one nation indivisible
and then uh to highlight of the
bicentennial in July 1976 for me
personally was with my father Jim
Harrigan who was also a State Rep just
like I am now gave a speech at the
dedication of a pocket park on Main
Street in Durham um
Bicentennial Park actually is still
there right at the corner of Mill Road
and Main Street my father unfortunately
died in 2011 so he will not be able to
give another speech and I'm sure he was
a much better speaker than I said he
would have given my speech would not
have been as good as his and um
but hopefully Durham and every other
town in New Hampshire will do something
to Mark July 4th 2026 and as proposed
I've got 15 members and there's a
like and we could possibly could
possibly pare it down I had like way
more than that my original draft to the
bill and uh Senator Waters he's one of
our co-sponsors would kind of
disappointed that was an excessively
large group so I've got 15 not three
members of the House three members of
the Senate and the uh
House of Senate delegations he's have at
least one member of the uh of the uh
of the minority party they'll be elected
by the uh the speaker and the Senate
President three members of the general
public so those would be appointed by
the governor and approved by the
executive Council
the governor himself or herself or or a
designee the Secretary of State or
designee the commissioner of national
cultural resources to designee the
chair of the usnh Board of Trustees for
designee the chair of the CCS SNH border
trustees or designee and uh the chair of
the New Hampshire Commission on Native
American Affairs or designees I just uh
I just thought I'd mention it because
where our state was founded on land that
was originally theirs and you know
they've never actually seized it back to
either us or the British but they're
but um you know they're they're here and
they're part of our community
the commissions like this usually start
to work a little bit sooner than four
years out
the commission I guess I won't say that
long word again but when the Senator
Shaheen sits on was established back in
2016 like I already said uh
commission for the 2019 celebration of
the state house why is Centennial was uh
started up in 2014 the
we also not in relatively recent years
we had a
we celebrate the bicentennial of the US
Constitution I think that commission
started more than four years in advance
and I think the
Vice New Hampshire Bicentennial
commission and uh
a lot of this and Crystal which um and
that was back a lot of that goes back
way before the online uh legislative
record is but I think it started
way back around 1966 and the 60s and
actually it kept going until like uh we
extended it several times we the New
Hampshire house not me personally I
wasn't there even uh
um they extended until 1991 so we're
kind of a
you know so but we've got plenty of time
to do something good and it probably
shouldn't
shouldn't be limited just to uh the
Declaration of Independence because
there's a lot of things that came up
happened before that a lot of things
that happened years after that including
a revolutionary war and you know the and
then eventually we'll have to celebrate
the 250th anniversary of the
Constitution
um so that's uh
one thing certainly I hope uh and just
I'll point out for your benefit uh Mr
chair the and now I forgot the exact
date but something like March 10th
1775 was the founding of the Marine
Corps so we'll definitely uh want to do
a few celebrations for that on in 2025
on March 10th or whatever the date may
be so
thank you November 10th I knew you'd
have that memorized let me open my mic
again November 10 1775. thank you for
coming thank you for correcting me and
make sure the official records uh
supports that so all right
so that is my uh
so that is that is my proposal um and um
I think it's relatively simple and it's
you know the something that is going to
be done uh done anyway and
well thank you uh representative I see
you keeping good company there with
representative
um wall and Marjorie Smith I'm kind of
insulted that Marjorie Smith's not here
to testify she let her know that okay
okay yes I mean she's it's for anyone
don't know Ahmad representative Smith
and I are good friends so yeah she had
she took a bit of a fall and she's
bouncing back okay well but you know I
give him my best yeah send my love yes
all right thank you will you take
questions yes I guess I should anyone
have questions uh representative
deschase yes I knew he'd have some yeah
yeah we we spoke before actually I I
conjectured before you showed up I'm
just gonna make a quick comment but
thank you for recognizing me Mr chair
thank you for taking my question I
mentioned to uh the chairman that I
would be willing to Guess that your
father had served on the bicentennial
and lo and behold that was correct I'd
remember that from your testimony the
other day earlier this week oh yeah
probably right in my family a lot so
yeah I was um so quick would you would
you be amiable to a uh to an amendment
by the committee to make the partisan
makeup on this commission equal
um
well that's great that's in your hands I
wouldn't consider that a deal breaker so
that's uh you know that's this is your
bill now so it's not mine so the
committee is certainly free to amend it
and that's uh that does also have the
advantage of reducing
reducing the size of the group a little
bit so now it's down to 11 so make it
easier easier for them to you know
to reach a consensus and so forth so
yeah that's uh
so I'm wouldn't say I'm against that so
when I wouldn't say I'm for it either
but I yeah
and we don't know which party will be
the majority like when the same well I
guess we will because it takes effect
on patches I guess we'll know like who's
going to be in majority and like
whenever the governor gets around the
signing it which so yeah that's that's
up to you I certainly think you
certainly should draw up an amendment to
that uh to that to do that if you feel
that's a good idea and it doesn't sound
terrible to me
could I have a Fallout uh I was also
just wondering and I'm I was talking to
you in uh one of the co-sponsors um
could you explain the reasoning behind
having the uh the chair of the
University system the chair of the
community college system uh you know the
chair of the trustees or one of their
designees on to this legislation I don't
I was kind of confused regarding um
because the commission could get their
input either way and ask them to set up
programming what's the reasoning for
having them also be a voting member uh
just they
this is at least in part A educational
effort so I figured they they both
and then they may even incorporate you
know integration will even affect what
they teach in their history curriculum
over the next several years so I I just
figured and I believe we did do
something similar with some some of the
previous commissions I think
um
I don't have a copy of here and I
haven't looked at it in a few few weeks
but they I think they think they're on
the bike I think they're on the
bicentennial the State House Commission
and then the also the uh
um and then there's also like that was a
similar makeup to the uh constant the
250 two ends of the anniversary of the
Constitution commission back in the 19
1990s so
yeah
certainly uh just one or two more
follow-ups Mr chairman
um so I was also just wondering about
the uh the the New Hampshire Commission
of Native American Affairs the chair of
that or a designee
um I I think it was kind of confusing
reading the first section of the bill as
to um so you want to also do the events
leading up so you'd also want to be
looking at Native American history too
in regards to how it relates to the
Declaration of Independence could you
could you kind of explain how you would
feel the commission would integrate that
and how this uh how this chair of the
New Hampshire commission Native American
Affairs would actually fit into this
whole equation well first of all I mean
I guess our state was uh Abernathy land
which they call it indicina that was
back before the English and then us
Americans
uh took over and
um
so there's a long and conflicted history
with the evanaki and other tribes but
there's also a
like but there's also been some
one thing that's especially relevant
that's a good thing probably is that the
U.S Constitution was facing large part
on a uh
Constitution that the the Iroquois and
other tribes uh
made up in the 18th century uh so
because um
one thing about one thing about this we
we kind of there's as much history
you know it's been there's more than 200
it's about two it's more than 250 years
before that that Europeans began coming
uh to the across the Atlantic Oceans
actually the pre-colonial history of
uh New Hampshire and the United States
in general is actually longer than like
the history of the United States as the
United States but I just felt they
deserved the place at the table
um
they actually I gotta tell frankly they
don't really consider that a date to
celebrate because things really actually
got worse for them at least immediately
after the uh After the Revolution
because they um you know they
they've they've reached sort of like a
they've reserved a state of code's
existence with the uh British
authorities and now they had like us now
they had the colonists were running the
show for ourselves and we weren't
necessarily uh we weren't necessarily
any more enlightened than the British
leaders have been when it came to
dealing with uh you know the indigenous
peoples so but I felt they deserved a
place at the table um if
them and it's up to the committee decide
what the membership should be so you
might want I mean see I do certainly
understand the general impetus to start
simplifying a little bit more because my
first draft was like even longer than
that and I was convinced to make it
shorter so uh just one more question Mr
chairman if I may go ahead yes
um I'm wondering if you um if the
sponsors would um would find a
permissible to add a like a veterans
Advisory Group to the commission I think
that as you mentioned you know obviously
our military and you know the uh the
early you know the early um
establishment of our military and
helping defend the colonies and the
militias played in an immense role in
the uh in the independence of our
country so I'm wondering if you would
think that would be a good thing for
this well it's not a bad idea and
probably the best candidate for that job
is uh sitting right here in front of me
but yes
but I thank you for that uh I want to
just run some by a few years ago this
committee uh we looked at the Indian
welfare which I thought was a great
thing
a lot of people didn't know and I didn't
understand windy and Welfare but after
doing some research
we had no tribes that settled in New
Hampshire
and we had no uh they tried the
abernakis and the other Indian groups
traveled through New Hampshire that's
why I'm glad you asked that question
there on the Indians here because they
traveled through New Hampshire but they
settled in Maine in Massachusetts and
New York and other Vermont or Canada but
not in New Hampshire at least we
couldn't find any data that supported
that when we did the Indian welfare
because we did pass to get the tribes
together here in New Hampshire so I just
wanted to throw that out there and for
welfare it doesn't mean like something
going on welfare means a program they
have for the Indians there to help them
financially education and other stuff if
they had land and other things well I
mean but I just wanted to put that out
there okay I
my view of the history is a little bit
different but I'm not necessarily the
definitive expert to it I didn't know if
I may so we can move on because it has
nothing to do with this I'm not sure if
you can get me some data on that I would
appreciate it later on because then
you'll be good education for us yeah but
rep you have a question uh thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question I'll
preface it by saying I I love I love
this bill I would have been happy to
have been a co-sponsor I think it's
wonderful
um
representative deseed's already
touched on one of one of my questions
about possibly this being a veterans
committee state federal to have a
veteran or some veterans presence so I
now that the committee will have the
bill maybe uh it could be somehow uh
that's up to you uh amended in that
fashion
um so it's it's a great idea I think
representative Deshay said on what I
think is a wonderful idea anyway I see
that you have the Secretary of State or
designee I'm not sure if secretary
Gardner was Secretary of State at that
time I think he came in just just after
that but I I like that but I also wanted
to just ask and I guess that would be up
to the committee now but the uh the
three New Hampshire signers
um Matthew Thornton William Whipple and
uh Josiah Bartlett
uh presumably hopefully have some
descendants I don't know who or where
they are but I also like the idea which
maybe we could talk about if if we can
find their descendants uh and involve
them I think maybe that's something we
maybe could could talk about as well so
anyway uh that was my question is is do
you think that it would be how would you
feel this being your bill if we tried to
integrate descendants of signers if you
can track them down that's fine so yeah
that's good but no objection I have no
objection to the idea thank you but they
could always be honorary speakers and
everything that the committee could put
together on is there okay is there any
other questions or anything for
um I want to thank you I appreciate it
if you if you have some history of the
Indians I'd be interested in reading
that because of you know I was very
interested in when I had that hearing
before okay
okay I'm sorry go ahead another question
um it's not a question but I just want
to thank you for bringing this this is
uh important to celebrate our history so
I appreciate this yes I'm I'm surprised
I was the one who brought it up but I
was just also just sort of looking
forward to well things that would Unite
about the you know about the United part
of the United States which we've been
kind of divided and things have been in
chaos in the last few years and also
this looked like something that probably
if we'd had like a normal the last few
years have been normal we probably would
have done this a few years ago but it
just also occurs just I think got lost
in the shuffle you know we were past you
know this
this year has been crazy enough and it's
normal compared to the two previous two
years so you know I think a lot of
things
this is like a little bit of unfinished
business that should have been done
earlier but better now than later better
now than never bringing it Forward there
and with that no more questions thank
you very much representative Hogan
with that I would like to my friend
Janet wall
you did a great job as a chairman in
legislative admin so I welcome you to my
committee
good afternoon good to see everyone
again for the record I'm Janet wall I
represent Durham and Madbury and I
signed on to this bill because I'm very
interested in the concept of it the bill
is flawed
um sorry representative Morgan I respect
all the people who have worked on this
bill especially the legislative service
attorney who drafted it but it is flawed
the first paragraph almost ends in what
we would consider something like a
dangling participle because it talks
about
if you look at lines six through ten he
talks about the American Revolution and
the events leading up to and including
the signing of the Declaration of
Independence but then it talks about at
the tail end a particular attention how
New Hampshire was involved but it
doesn't say in Fault With the events
leading up to and including the signing
it's just I I played with some of the
language on it and I'm willing to work
with anyone on an amendment um there's a
way to take that final
um
phrase with particular attention to the
ways in which New Hampshire was involved
and put it further up in the paragraph
So it shows the way New Hampshire was
involved with events leading up to and
including and signing the Declaration of
Independence I think there's a way to
take the wording we have here
and clarify this so that people realize
you're not just working on the
Declaration of Independence but but
indeed the events leading up too so I I
just say this is a very awkward
introductory paragraph for such an
important group of people to work
together I served on the Lincoln
commission and I want to say that the
number of members on this commission is
not unusual but I didn't bring that
legislation in to show you it's up to
the committee I would get it if you want
it to see who was included in that
because that might help the committee in
terms of the membership and in terms of
the membership there is an error on page
two lines two and three
the first meeting of the commission
shall be called by the member of The
Joint legislative historic committee I'm
on that committee I have been for a long
time but that committee is not mentioned
as being part of this Commission
and so I think that where was that again
lines two and three a member of The
Joint legislative historical committee
and I can't find it listed as a member
of the commission
I see Department of Natural and cultural
resources I see house members senate
members but I don't see anything about
the joint historic committee so is it
possible I mean to say you're going to
be working on the amendment right uh
yeah we can um it sounds like
representative walls get a lot of
experience in this area maybe you can
communicate with her and come up with
the right Amendment yeah I have some
stuff written down right now and I know
you have some language already for the
um for the uh what's it called for the
updated language of paragraph one I
think we could add sorry you know I know
I'm interjecting all of a sudden but um
I think we can add two members from each
one from each party from the join um
historical commission that you just
mentioned no no no you don't think that
daughter respect Mr chairman and
representative yes
um there is
a joint historical legislative committee
and with it has senators and it has
State reps
and you can't just I mean you could very
well draw one of the members of that and
put it in with this language here but it
doesn't work
if you need that member to call the
first meeting that member needs to be
listed as a member of this commission
and that member is not listed
well that's kind of that
maybe I'm confused now that's what I
meant like in the amendment we add
you know people from that joint
committee to the commission
we don't usually leave things like that
to chance we're usually very specific in
terms of who is a member of what I think
the chairman understands that
um it's it's not just saying well golly
gee whiz will choose somebody and
hopefully they're from that committee
and I respect what you're saying because
of the number you'll be having from the
house and the Senate but at the same
time it's very important when you have a
member from The Joint historical
committee listed as a member not by name
but listed as a position on the
committee because that number is calling
the first meeting and that's
traditionally what we do here
mm-hmm right okay
um what I'd like to um do and I
appreciate you bringing this up with
your years of experience on this here
um is it possible like I said that you
could representative shakes to make sure
because it's it's very important for us
to get the right language out of this
committee and not something that's half
but half-assed uh you know that we're
putting out so uh it would be beneficial
for this here and for the future of this
um you know anniversary of the
Declaration to be done properly to sit
down if possible will representative the
shares it may be somebody else on your
side that want to sit down and help with
that amendment to make sure and we'll
we'll exec this on next Friday uh to do
it proper and do it right because I I
support the bill yeah but I just want to
make sure we're not embarrassed setting
something out that's not proper hey can
I and I respect you because you've been
around a long time and you've been
involved thank you I would be very happy
to do that and again I
you know the language for that first
paragraph we really do need to clean
that up and make it and to clarify it
right and I think we can do that and
again I had thought of proposing an
amendment just to add that member from
The Joint legislative historical
committee but then that put 16 onto this
commission and usually we have an odd
number as opposed to an even number and
I can get information from the Lincoln
Commission
bill that we had setting that up back
when as to how they did that if you
would want yeah I'd be interested to see
a copy of that okay yeah I I bought can
I I apologize for the drafting errors I
agree 100 with what representative wall
just said about the historical
commission so yes and I'm sorry okay
sorry about the drafting area no no
that's okay that's honestly I'm glad
that you have some experience here that
you brought on board with it and I'm
sure if mod Schmidt was here forget
about it you know I mean he'd be rocking
my boat yeah I was around when it was
signed yeah well actually I will put one
personal thing in I am a daughter of the
American Revolution uh colonel stittney
from here in Concord was my ancestor so
since he's talking about his father
um you know this is important but it's
not about me it's not about my ancestors
it's about us right and um I and then
someone asked me why are we asking for
this so far in advance it takes a lot of
time to get something big organized
we've done it without the commissions on
this stuff here before okay right so
this is nothing new you're right
okay uh any questions for representative
walls
do you oh you had a question
if feeling does me uh would you believe
that my uh fourth grade grandfather
fought under uh Colonel Stickney at
Bennington and uh they did fight in
Bennington right directly under General
Stark he was uh
at Bennington under Colonel he was a
stickney's militia at Bennington he was
my fourth great grandfather my fifth
grade grandfather would you believe was
the first Deputy of the provincial
Congress which was the Revolutionary
assembly in
1775-76 so anyway uh would you believe
so I believe that and I find it
fascinating history is wonderful we're
all lucky to be here making history and
living history and thank you for sharing
that information we'll talk sure thank
you for taking my question right well
it's no more questions and do you have
any that you'd be able to get with her
on as far as if I was on the beginning
of it and other stuff that we can make
sure that this is tightened and
straightened out yeah I have some I have
some notes down and I can do me to talk
with her yeah yeah and then that way
they'll uh we make sure we get it done
right and up there I assume you're going
to close the hearing correct yes okay
all right Mr chairman what I'll do then
is if there's someone still down in
research I'll go and get that Lincoln
commission information I'll give it to
you oh okay awesome I think thank you
very much thank you for your interest
okay I'm going to close the hearing on
and let me see
that was pretty interesting there uh
you learn a lot in this committee here
especially like I said I learned about
the Indians and I didn't want to vote on
something I had no clue on until we
started doing some research
and it was a good team effort
I don't care
okay
I closed the hearing so we're gonna be
beating back again here in about
seven minutes four fifteen so I don't
think I can get the exec done on the
bill so I'll have to do it right after
that bill
thank you
I know
and then
let's do it online
yeah
we could probably
okay
we're doing this
so um
foreign
thank you
thank you representative
okay we're getting ready to start the
hearing
uh representative you submitted a pink
Cod
oh no I'm so sorry thank you for
reminding me
yeah
I didn't know I didn't
yeah yeah I probably didn't because I
didn't expect to do it yeah
I'll go with well when I get a chance
I'll get a cut
yes
representative uh she did a great job
there well she's amazing when she was
the chair of legislative very fair yeah
she's a good girl
that's why I was hoping Mike Schmidt
came in here so I can mess with him
her and her husband her husband I were
good friends there he said I'd go Lobby
guy and we went on a trip to church
[Music]
oh I'm easy okay I'm gonna open up the
hearing on 1284 which is an act
established in a committee to study the
effects of deportation of primary
earners on the family members who are in
a United States citizens and I'm gonna
know what is that God
and I'm going to welcome representative
Nicole Klein welcome to the committee hi
thank you for the record I'm
representative Nicole Klein Knight I
represent Manchester Hillsboro District
11. and I just want to say how grateful
I am to this committee this is the third
time in just two years that this
committee has heard the reasons why this
bill is necessary
in New Hampshire
immigrant-led households in the state
paid
six
hundred and eighty eight point three
million dollars in federal taxes and
195.7 million in state and local taxes
in 2018.
that is
um legal immigrant-led households
undocumented undocumented immigrants in
New Hampshire paid an estimate of 14.3
million in federal taxes and 6.1 million
in state and local taxes in 2018.
in 2018 immigrants accounted for 21 of
business owners small business owners in
New England alone
I have tried very very hard to get the
raw data on exactly how much our
taxpayers are spending
on deporting people
whether it's putting the family that's
left behind because they are U.S
citizens on food stamps whether it's
paying their heat and electric bills in
their groceries whether it's
adding to Public School Systems because
their education is delayed from trauma
I cannot find that research and I think
it's imperative
for our state to know where our money's
going in an honest way
we can't blindly be throwing money away
that is fiscally irresponsible
thank you so much for your time well
thank you uh will you take questions
sure
okay I as you know I've been on this
committee for 15 years as you say this
has come to me many times
and every time you come the bill comes
here I sit and I think wow you already
did your homework you already did the
study you already have the data you
already know but then when I think about
it the U.S Constitution as I stated
before and I'm only doing this for my
committee which is a lot of new members
here and they put 150 in what they're
doing that the U.S Constitution talks
about it's the federal government
okay we already know we have no control
over deporting I fought for
a family in my neighborhood that I
always thought were citizens I never
knew that they weren't the children were
because they were born I guess their
mother came over here pregnant and then
had the baby and they ended up getting
educated and everything owned a home in
my district but the federal government
came in and kicked them out there was
nothing we could do
um you know and we have no control over
it it's a federal issue so this is why
you just keep coming to us here
we have two senators and two
congresswomen that Democrats and they've
been in charge for many a long time have
you gone to them yes I have I'm on the
record actually on WMUR you can look it
up it's on YouTube calling out all four
of their names to do more and to
research this
okay and um for the record sorry to
interrupt chair I just want to say this
doesn't affect deportation at all as is
the federal government's responsibility
this is simply
a free study committee that volunteers
will put in their time to gather data on
where our people's money is going and I
think that is our responsibility as a
state
when you say our people are you talking
like for instance the taxpayers money to
pay and educate people that come over
our country illegal is that what you're
talking about we want to figure out how
much dollars are going into that
I want to go I want to know how much
we're spending on taking care of the
families that are left behind after we
Deport a primary bread earner
okay are there any other questions
um yes
thank you Mr chair and thank you Nicole
for a representative Klein Knight for
your testimony
um
and I think I think this is a clarifying
question so it is we are we're studying
not the impact on the federal government
but rather the impact on our state and
local municipalities and studying you
know whether it's you know we have to
provide uh shelters whether we have to
provide if that family all of a sudden
no longer can pay like so where so would
you say that we're really kind of
studying like what happens to our state
after this happens
thank you so much for your question
representative I think um it affects our
budget where our money goes how much
money is going to the food stamp program
how much money is going to public
education special education housing
costs for families that can no longer do
not have a supporter
and if 21 of New England businesses rely
on
immigration and immigrants to do the
work that nobody wants to do
specifically health care workers nurses
labor force workers a lot of small
businesses depend on these people and
even though they they might be getting
paid in a certain way they're
contributing taxes they're helping us
get money and then we are shooting
ourselves in the foot and locally it's
unfair to our constituents not to study
this and that's all this bill does and
by refusing to study something like this
is a slap in the face to the money of
our people in this state
representative Chase
uh thank you for recognizing Mr chairman
and thank you representative Klein
Knight for taking my question I was
wondering on um on line 10 under duties
it says uh quote the committee shall the
effects of deportation of primary
earners on family members who are United
States citizens I I believe this is a
typo did you bring an amendment prepared
for making the correction I did not it
was a big catch
um I would go I will gladly do that if I
am allowed to do that
but I don't think that a typo should
warrant the death of such an important
bill to our taxpayers
thank you
anyone else uh yes representative thank
you Mr chair for recognizing me thank
you representative Klein Knight for
presenting this I just to uh maybe I
could just tell you a short very short
story and see what you if this is
relevant to what you're saying there was
a family in Milford eliasar Ayala this
hit the press this is a big story
where he was stopped for some routine
Road stop
um he had come as a teenager a young
teenager to the U.S was not fully
documented he had I think four children
all of whom were U.S citizens he was
then ended up in an ice facility for a
year I was only I I became involved when
to consult with the school district as
the kids started to develop
school-related problems because their
father was away they also you know the
old well the sun started had to go get a
job to support the family family was
under tremendous strain food stamps the
whole thing that they had never done
before because the father
had been a a good supporter of the
family so I'm wondering about school
costs and IEP costs suddenly all the
kids are on IEPs because they're
developing mental health problems and
psychologists are involved in special
education is involved whereas previously
they had not been involved is that the
kind of thing and I wonder what is it
Ayala multiplied by what kind of a
number but I have no idea we're talking
about millions of our of our taxpayers
dollars right now
so yeah I'm just so is that the time in
order to to really dive into that we
would need the study committee
if I if I may ask um
once you do the study and you find out
okay millions of dollars which you
already know you already got that answer
coming in here
what then what's this what does it prove
what does it do
well it would assist our federal
government as you say in their
responsibility to make changes
okay now my next thing to add is because
like I said see in this here coming many
times in the same time we've had Senator
Shaheen Senna Hassan Uh custom I can't
believe because he's only been there two
terms I think and maybe come to his
flights with him but
how come
they can't get the answer it's a federal
issues this is what I'm trying to get
across no matter how much we study this
issue it's still
immigration is a federal issue uh
welfare department studies involved with
this stuff uh you know with TANF and all
that good stuff there the churches that
we had the last time they know exactly
who they have and who the workers are
and who got deported
I'm just asking
with all due respect to simply not study
this issue is doing a disservice to our
taxpayers
okay I'm representative Chase
I just had a well thank you for
recognizing me Mr chair and um thank you
for taking my question representative
Klein Knight I just had a question you
really want a um a comprehensive study
it sounds like for this issue but um I'm
a little bit com wouldn't a commission
be even more comprehensive bringing in
stakeholders bringing the federal
government maybe even bringing in people
from you know the yeah from the uh well
I know we wouldn't have the statutory
power actually to do it but to request
someone from the Senator's office either
the Senators to come in I'm kind of
confused this seems like
um we might end up having legislators
who have no purview over this issue
constitutionally based on the Commerce
Clause giving a recommendation that can
only be acted upon by federal officials
so I'm confused why you didn't do a
commission
thank you so much for your question
um and I can amend the language to
actually include that so good catch on
that but if I can't get a simple
study committee response from this body
there's I don't believe that such a
thing like that you know going all the
way it wouldn't make a difference I can
put that in the language the intent will
still be the same so what you decide if
this is something worth studying is the
main point here today
uh representative Moffett thank you Mr
chair thank you representative Klein
I've taken my question
um are you aware of comparable
committees perhaps from other states
that maybe have gotten into this area
that might provide some sort of models
for us to to look at they're all Loosely
based basically they're saying you know
we know we spend Millions on our our
Public Schools we know we spend Millions
on our budget to pay for rent and board
and he we know we spend
just we're hemorrhaging money but
nobody's really been studying this at
such an in-depth level for for state by
state case basis there's a federal
census and you can go to the the federal
website for that and it'll show you how
much we spend at the federal level to
deport these people which is also this
is billions of dollars so that's a
separate thing as your chairman stated
that is the federal government's
responsibility but we would be leading
the way for all 50 states
to be fiscally responsible in showing
that where our money is going how much
we can do to help
stop wasting it
they follow up yeah so okay thank you
thank you so what I'm hearing is that
this you see this as being kind of a
prototype and you you've looked into
this and this has not been done to your
knowledge in any other states like this
so this so there is no model to look at
this would be a prototype is what you're
saying yeah and I don't think that there
is anything wrong with studying how much
money our taxpayers in New Hampshire are
spending to take care of other people's
families
thank you
when you brought that up there first
thing I did put a note here is stop
wasting because on a study if in this
study here if I as a taxpayer if the
numbers came out and I was told how much
money I'm paying now in your District
Manchester I heard they got over 60 or
70 different languages teachers they had
to hire to support this
don't you think that would be a red flag
on this program that taxpayers will say
what we're spending that much money now
I see why our taxes are so high is that
what you're looking for or I mean I'm
confused on what you're actually looking
for I'm looking for a way to show where
our money's going in a transparent way
and I think that we owe the people of
New Hampshire transparency when we spend
their money on on issues like this
I think we had a question in the back
there yes sir thank you Mr chairman and
this it isn't so much a question but it
perhaps
um an offer I'm I'm happy to draft an
amendment to this bill uh that turns the
committee into a commission
uh if we think that that's the route
that we want to go it sounds like that
could be helpful representative deshay's
sound like you want to go in that
direction if it by having some other
stakeholders come to the table we might
be able to develop some better Solutions
yeah
I'm going to ask a question of the um of
you representative Clem Knight real
quick and thank you Mr chair I'm kind of
you know I think more of what I was
trying to get to was understand because
this is very Broad in Latitude right
we're talking about
um you know a committee made up of
legislators that have no purview over
this issue that will be looking at the
effects of deportation amongst primary
earners family members who are U.S
citizens in this entire State I hear you
talking a lot about that you want to
look at the costs so there's no there's
nothing that's really narrowed the scope
of this to the cost to taxpayers it just
says you know to how it affects right an
effect that could be socially
emotionally cost logistically I mean
there's a there's a whole bunch so I'm
kind of confused because you're talking
a lot about the tax costs why not narrow
the scope of this to the cost to U.S
taxpayers and I'm also and I'll you know
I'll ask I'll make the question two-fold
too has the federal government funded
any studies to look at the cost of this
or done any studies itself because they
usually Federal government's a king of
studies I'd be pretty hard-pressed not
to imagine they haven't funded or at
least a university that's publicly
funded hasn't done a study on this
thank you so much for your two Quest
two-parter representative
um I'd be amenable to an amendment that
narrows the scope to just our New
Hampshire state taxes if you want to
start there starting in the right
direction is something and I'm always
willing to
um compromise on that and you know the
other issues they can come in the next
couple years or not at all the most
important thing is here is how we're
spending our our New Hampshire residents
tax dollars so you're right
and if that is okay with representative
Wilhelm when he drafts an amendment to
narrow the scope with with such language
that you suggested that would be that
would be great
the other part of your question the
federal government does
tally the data on how a long residents
stay so we're still paying but if we're
paying federally for that that's a step
that's the separate issue
um your federal tax dollars are going to
house
um these immigrants until they're
deported so you're paying for room and
board and meals and they're plane
tickets and that can take months to to
even I've I've known some immigrants
stay in the jail system or the
incarcerated for a over a year or so it
depends when it's available to deport
them back to their origin not not every
immigrant is from this same country that
comes here so that is available online
the census does the federal government
does make that available to everybody
I may be wrong but I don't know if
there's somebody in here is expert in
this area but I thought if you weren't
if you didn't have a green card or you
were in a U.S citizen you didn't qualify
for TANF in New Hampshire that any
monies for this stuff they're bringing
them with Federal money somebody help me
out on that are you aware of that does
that
I
can't hear you I would probably assume
that you yourself aren't uh probably
can't get that but like like I said like
most of the stuff in the bill would
probably be your Offspring or like
somebody in the family who is the U.S
citizen would qualify for that I think
that's the I think that's the issue is
like these mixed status families you
know it's you have a parent who's
undocumented but then like a somebody
else okay this is something I guess we
can debate when we uh on the bill when
we get forward I'm just putting it out
there I'm hoping maybe you have an
answer for that uh because are we gonna
would this study start investigating
looking at the federal government how
much money they're bringing in here when
they bring kids or whoever they're
bringing in uh to the state
it would look at where our taxes are
going in terms of the budget on you know
if there's a certain amount of U.S born
uh children that were born to illegal
immigrant status
it would look at cost per family it
would I hope determine exactly where our
money's going
um besides federal dollars but we have
um we have that in I believe the fiscal
committee could help us with
how much we get in federal aid and where
it goes every year so that that wouldn't
affect this at all
um Mr chairman
um this is actually quite surprising uh
that you asked that I was actually
looking at the application for
assistance yesterday because I I was
applying and there is a question on
state assistance that asks if you are a
U.S citizen okay thank you I'm not
familiar that's why I asked I thought
you know somebody would know uh yes you
had a representative for the yes uh
thank you chairman my question is uh the
reason if I'm understanding correctly
the reason that this would be a state
level committee is to really focus on
the cost of the state on the burden uh
or the burden of the state on these
children that are are left behind in the
United States is that correct
uh thank you so much for your question
representative yes especially we're in
quite a bind right now as a state since
we only get our tax stream from Raising
property taxes it affects all of us here
to keep doing that to take care of other
people's families seems like a real
egregious mistake on our parts as
leaders
follow-up Mr chair yes follow up good uh
and this is a second question could the
findings put more pressure on the
delegation to actually act on this issue
I can't say to that
dance help you out there what makes a
difference is each and every one of you
signing a letter and send it to your
delegation and asking them for the help
there because it's a shame because all
if I was involved in like involved as
heavy as you are I'd be over at the um
Council and I'm talking with the people
over there on the finances how much
money is going out and I'd already know
I wouldn't even need a study committee
and have to pay taxpayers money for it
can I respond thank you so much chair so
um I met with Annie Custer like I said
I've been on our state TV asking
representative Custer representative
Pappas
Senator Hassan and uh Senator Shaheen
I've named them all by name and this was
a couple years ago I've been at this for
a very long time to show a
responsibility well our responsibility
is as Leaders where we're spending our
people's money and how it affects the
state and frankly again this doesn't
harm anybody by getting that information
and I have to say by not getting that
information we're doing a great
disservice to taxpayers of the state
well okay thank you are there any other
questions
no what that uh I thank you for your uh
testimony and seeing that when there's
no other cards I'm gonna
have you okay you're going to speak okay
um thank you so much for your time I
have to go back to myself you know I I I
there's a great intentions if the
federal government wasn't written the
Constitution the way it is I'd be on
this in a heartbeat would you but I
would say what you're what are you
afraid of finding out there's nothing
I'm afraid of
not doing then you would support this
yeah the only person I'm afraid of was
my father and he's dead
okay
um
oh there we go I'm working now can you
hear me okay uh representative Perez uh
welcome
thank you Mr speaker thank you for the
opportunities pick up in support of this
bill
the reason that I'm I'm speaking in
support of this bill is because
it is critical not for us to know
exactly not only for us to know exactly
how much money that we're spending to
support this family after their uh
someone who is the supporter for this
family gets supported but it is critical
for us to know how much taxes that these
people pay and how many people how many
of these people they get on the border
their own businesses and they are hiring
our citizens of this country how much
money are we losing and
it is it is important like
another representative I say to instead
of and have it a committee doing a
commission because I've been speaking to
that that our delegation with the
Senators and Congressional Delegation
and I've been pointing that up that it
is critical for us to know exactly what
are we doing what are we doing to help
our communities how much are we
now seeing how much data the immigrants
are contributing to to the economy in
New Hampshire it is critical it is
critical for us to know how much money
these people pay in in taxes and where
is this money is going when these oh how
much money are we losing would these
people get the quarter and how much
money are we spending to supporting the
families when they're staying behind
and that's why I I'm supporting this
bill because
we want we want to show our in our
delegation you know what exactly is
happening in New Hampshire and I how you
say you know data getting involved get
the offices involved so they can see or
they can bring what they have for
information maybe that's something that
we don't know and they have maybe it's
something that we can bring it to them
and they don't have that information so
I I think it is really good to have
these
commission to study the issues when the
bread maker or the or the person who
support and the family gets the porter
not just like not just because we want
to see how much money are we spending to
support the the families when they stay
behind
but it's critical for us as a state to
see how much money I will listen with
this person get supported especially if
it's our business owner and then how
many people they've been out of work
because those people they you know
they've been having dismiss and they've
been hiring these people Americans to
work in the business of how much money
are we losing
and that's you know that's that's what I
have to say and maybe I'm wrong but you
know I for me I think it's it is
critical for us to do the study and see
how much money really is causing to our
taxpayers
all right thank you for your testimony I
got one question for you
um
taxes are private it's against the law
to pull taxes uh for my taxes to be
you've looked at and how would the study
committee uh do that
maybe you know we can have members of
the community that they've been impacted
in in this issue to bring that
information you know sometimes people
they're they're willing to get that
information for this first study
committee so I I don't see a problem
because I think uh like another state
representative he was talking about
someone who was
um close to be deporter Mr ajala and uh
people like him we can bring them to
testify and you know I know that he was
one of one of the people that he owns a
business and he was providing a job to
other people and not just that but
paying taxes and uh and I know we can
get more people like him to bring that
information to us so they can help us to
study those issues
okay thank you
um any other questions for
yes go ahead thank you Mr chair so
uh representative do you do you think
our immigration system is broken
it is broken you know it's it's about
past time that we do something to fix
the problem but I think doing this is
going to help us to show not just the
senator the Congressional Delegation but
nationally that we we taken we're taking
the first step to show how critical is
for us to work on fixing the problem
it's been happening for so long and it's
time for us to fix it but we cannot do
it as a local so he has to make sure
that this commission is bringing like
the chair say Brandon that the
Congressional Delegation and this you
know everyone who's involved nationally
to make sure that they understand
exactly how these issues hurting our
economy and how these issues can be
fixed and we're fixing our broken system
okay you had a follow-up
okay thank you
um with that yes
go ahead
uh thank you for taking my question
representative thank you for recognizing
me Mr chair so I'm I'm still confused
though um you know if we're talking
about how you know currently we can't
find a lot of this publicly promulgated
information how how do we expect six
legislators to find this information
when it's just a legislative study I
mean I'm very much confused this is
you're talking about tons of federal
information tons of State information
voluntarily getting information from
um from local communities and local
organizations and everything I mean this
is a massive undertaking it's
logistically huge a lot of data and I'm
just unsure how six six legislators who
are volunteers and during campaign
season by the way that's just a reality
are going to be able to serve on this
committee constitute a quorum and have
the time to find all this I mean this is
something that you could give a research
Grant to a public university for five
years and they would only be you know
touching the tip of the iceberg a number
of these things so how how do you think
these six legislators are going to be
able to actually find the information
that you you won't expect them to find
into would be able to comprise it and
compile it in a way for people to digest
um to be honest to to answer that
question
um I can't I probably ignore it I don't
know much maybe I don't know everything
that I need to know as a legislator
because this is my first turn
but I wonder if we we instead of them
doing uh the committee we're doing a
commission can we have members of the
public part of the commission
so if we can have members of the public
be part of the commission we have so
many organizations that already been
working with these communities and I'm
I'm the chair of the Latino caucus and
it's a shadow Latino caucus I work with
a lot of different organizations in our
state then they're more than willing and
more than the more than happy to help us
to to work in getting these information
together so I don't think it's going to
be an issue for us to gather the
information because I know
I I have
plenty organizations behind us they can
help us to gather this information not
just the sixth uh members so that of the
house can you know do it do the um the
study
any other questions
all right thank you and with that uh
fellow Representatives on this committee
if you're going to testify don't throw
me a curveball and just sit there and
wait the last minute we're ready to
close and I'm trying to move this
committee along I appreciate if you're
going to testify you get up if you're a
co-sponsor you sit back there and you
submit your card so we all know because
we're playing with time right now okay
it's a courtesy thing to let us know
okay and I understand you're are you a
freshman okay
all right thank you because I'm
okay well sit down and we'll testify but
I appreciate it next time if you're
going to testify you put your card in
like everyone else submit it so we know
and we can plan accordingly because it's
very disrespectful for the chairman
thinking I'm moving along to get his
home and then you know somebody's
waiting the last second and hiding it
hard thank you
okay do we have a card for her right
here
thank you okay uh representative toll
you have the floor
last year
um we had huge attendance for this bill
and so I don't want to forget that
testimony I want to remind people of
what was said here because our citizens
took the time to come out here and speak
and so I think that information is
critical and I'm going to be speaking to
that in my testimony so honorable
colleagues my name is Amanda Elizabeth
toll I represent the city of keen at
large I'm speaking in support of hb1284
which I am a co-sponsor of this bill
establishes a committee to study the
effects of deportation of primary
earners of family members who are United
States citizens last legislative session
we had a very informative and moving
hearing for this bill the vast majority
of public participation at the hearing
was in favor of this bill
at that hearing we heard compelling
information from representatives from
non-profits including the American
friends service committee and Catholic
Charities along with information from a
retired Doctor Who had done extensive
work with the Red Cross we also heard
from many immigrants themselves about
how deportations have harmed their
families and their friends
collectively they presented information
that made clear the devastating economic
and humanitarian impact of deportation
of primary earners it was especially
heartbreaking to hear about how our
children our children are being harmed
highlighted at this hearing was the
psychological pain caused by the
absolute Terror families experience when
losing a loved one to deportation and
the grief they feel in the aftermath
additionally it was brought to our
attention the devastating toll
deportation takes on mental and physical
health of children Maggie forgarti noted
that these impacts on developing
children last a lifetime saying we hear
this from guidance counselors School
nurses and teachers
deportation also has a severe economic
impact a gentleman who worked for
Catholic Charities said there are
approximately 15 000 undocumented
immigrants in New Hampshire according to
the new American economy study of 2018.
he went on to present information about
how millions of dollars of buying power
this represents and how contrary to
popular opinion immigrants contribute to
both state and federal taxes moreover we
had other speakers who highlighted that
after deportations families headed by a
single parent suffer from economic
insecurity which creates a need for them
to require food stamps Section 8 Housing
and other critical social services this
makes clear that deportation impacts
taxpayers in New Hampshire this rebuts
the argument that this study shouldn't
take place because it's a federal issue
deportation directly impacts the
pocketbooks of our constituents
it's clear
that while we have much anecdotal
evidence about the impacts of
deportation of primary earners but no
Statewide data collection we have data
elements in very local places like
school districts Municipal welfare
offices and state Human Service offices
but it hasn't been woven together into a
state narrative historically some
colleagues have implied that a
non-profit could compile this we should
not shift government responsibility for
the well-being of our constituents to
non-government organizations the
authority of a state or legislative
study would hold more weight in both
encouraging participation and being
respected for policy determination we
need this study to collect reputable
data on a Statewide level to inform
public policy that leads to the best
economic and humanitarian outcomes for
New Hampshire residents thank you I will
not be taking questions
okay thank you for your testimony I
think I got something to add since I was
responsible on the last one there if I
made to your testimony there
the people that showed up the last time
it was quite and I really felt bad for
them because all those people that came
in here was under false pretenses
thinking that a study committee was
going to do wonders for them and we I
try to explain to them over and over
that it was the Federal Government not
the state we have no accountability on
immigration and nobody wanted to listen
but people out there are giving them
poor people false information that they
can come here to the state and wear the
answers the study committee is I mean I
I can't support it I'm just being
straightforward with you because I would
be given false information to people
that six legislators will come forward
and give the straight scoop and what
good does it do when the federal
government is the one who is a state
federal law in order to fix this uh
State U.S legislators senators in
congress have to change the law right
now we have immigration laws that are
not being held accountable for so I
since you wouldn't take questions I
think I owed it to you the answer on the
way I felt with all them people back
there and the last time were children I
felt so bad for them because they were
given promises that we were going to
save the world for them and there was
not a damn thing that we could do no
matter how much money we figure they're
spending no matter what all you're going
to do is say oh the taxpayers are
spending more money on the on them and I
felt bad I have him my family's all
immigrants came over from Italy so I
understand fully
but the law is the law so I thought I
would throw that out there on my
feelings on the last time with that is
anyone else going to want to gonna speak
am I any more surprises
okay with that I'm going to close the
hearing on 1284 and are we on board with
um
yes
we are
okay
I mean I actually felt bad for all those
people
hi oh okay come on up